So, ich bin am Start
Wir machen heute nix
Wir sitzen heute einfach nur da
Haben die Klimaanlage an
Und gucken uns
Irgendwie ein bisschen Zeug an
Das sieht so bescheuert aus
Ja
Übrigens, einer meiner Lieblings
Subreddits in letzter Zeit hier
Was letzte Preis
Beste
Was letzte Frau
Waschmaschinen, oh je
Schnell, jetzt kommen die Feministen wieder
In den Stream
Was letzte Preis
Brudi ist scheiß
Gebt ihr 500
Ja, das will ich auch immer als Antwort haben, wenn ich mein Gaming-PC
Verkaufe
Brudi ist scheiß, gebt ihr 500
Ja, das sind Verschreiber, die sind nicht lustig
Ja, der Patrick wusste ich das
Der guckt das auch
Was letzte Preis, beste
Was letzte Tim
Kennen wir uns bei Versand auf 120 Euro einigen
Blablabla
Die Leute sind teilweise
Aber ich meine, es scheint ja zu funktionieren
Habt ihr schon mal
Ebay-Kleinanzeigen verwendet?
Ebay-Kleinanzeigen oder irgendwie
Oder wie heißt das in Österreich?
Willhaben.at
Oder sowas
Oh ne, geh mal fort
Genau, mein Cousin ist dumm
Der macht das
Hahaha
Haha
Tschuldigung
Hahaha
Oder
Oder wie, wie auch immer das ging
Haha
Tschuldigung
Genau
Haha
Tschuldigung
Wobei, da sind echt lustige Sachen dabei
Also
Ich mach jetzt mal kurz den E-Rack
Sind echt lustige Sachen dabei, ne?
Also
Wenn man sich mal anguckt
Hier, hot
Äh
Ok, Tschuldigung
Haha
Das ist ja
Letzter Preis bitte
Ich hab noch gesagt 80
Ok, schrulligum
Hahaha
Was auch immer
Das ist schon wieder so doof, ey
Das ist der Cousin hier
Das ist der Cousin
Insgesamt bei 11 Euro
Ich mach schon keine Auge
Was auch immer, ja
Mein Cousin aus Gelsenkirchen kann abholen kommen
Hahaha
Das ist doch dumm, da war
Da sind schon lustige Sachen dabei, ey
Der Echsen-Wentsch-Dude ist auch geil gewesen
Du hast immer so absolute Big-Brain-Typen irgendwie auf diesen Anzeigenportalen
Wo man sich echt denkt, wie schaffen das manche überhaupt zu überleben
Also haben die
Was haben die an der Stelle, wo normale Leute ihr Hirn haben?
Ja, das weiß man nicht so genau
Ich hab heute von Amazon die Nachricht gekriegt, dass mein
Fuck
Dass mein MonkaS-T-Shirt auf dem Weg ist
Beste
Ah, kommt neuer
Ja, stirb du Echsen-Wentsch
Das ist richtig dumm, ey
Der Typ verkauft nen Laptop
Und die erste Frage ist
Ist Sky inklusive?
Hä?
Warum schreibst du es da dran?
Stirb du Echsen-Wentsch
Also irgendwie
Ich bin noch nie in die Versuche gekommen überhaupt
Da irgendwie eBay Kleinanzeigen oder so irgendwas zu verwenden
Ja
Er müsste jetzt eigentlich die Kategorie geändert haben auf Just Chatting
Hoff ich mal
Just Chatting?
Hat er das jetzt geändert?
Ich sehe es in meiner Vorschau nicht
Hat er, sehr schön
Bist du gerade im Discord?
Nee, aber ich kann ins Discord gehen
Was ist denn im Discord?
Ja, ich hab gesehen
Also, der Bauer hat ein neues Video
Worauf er sich drüber aufregt, dass
Hab ich nur in der Vorschau gerade auf dem Tablet gesehen
AMD vs. Intel, wir müssen reden
Das muss man uns nämlich mal anhören
Weil ich hab es nur in der Vorschau gesehen, eben auf dem Tablet
Und irgendwie geht es wohl darum, dass
Also, so wie ich das verstanden habe aus den Comments
Wie gesagt, ich habe es mir noch nicht angeguckt
Dass Intel oder AMD, einer von beiden jetzt quasi Leuten auf YouTube
Irgendwie einreden will, sie sollen von dem anderen Hersteller nichts mehr zeigen oder sowas
Das müssen wir uns mal anhören
Ja, weiß gar nicht, was da geht
Aber ich vermute mal sowas in der Richtung, laut den Kommentaren
Das gucken wir uns mal an
Wollte ich mir nämlich auch die ganze Zeit schon angucken
Da habe ich es schon mal gesehen
Da habe ich mir gedacht, komm, wir können uns ja auch im Stream zusammen angucken
Hast du schon MonkaVin gesehen?
Ja, klar habe ich MonkaVin gesehen schon
Okay, also, was ist hier los?
So, es ist mal wieder soweit
Wir machen ein Video, das mir immer besonders Spaß macht
Denn wir reden über die Intel vs. AMD Thematik
Die bei mir auf dem Kanal, die eigentlich bei allen YouTubern auf dem Kanal
Bei Tech-YouTubern immer wieder aufkommt
Bei mir irgendwie in letzter Zeit ganz besonders
Irgendwo kann ich es verstehen
Aber wenn wir so die Historie betrachten, dann auch wiederum nicht
Ich habe mir ein paar Notizen gemacht
Erstmal, dieses Video entsteht gerade weil ich jetzt aktuell viel AMD-Thematiken behandle
Und dann eben viel Kritik aufkommt und sagt
Oh Roman, du machst wieder nur Anti-AMD-Content
Das sind so Fanboys immer
Ich finde das so schlimm
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern, wo das PSN-Down war zum Beispiel?
Das ist schon ein paar Jahre her
Der erste oder einer der größeren PSN-Ausfälle
Vielleicht erinnert sich der eine oder andere noch daran
Und das geile war, die Leute
Also, was weiß ich, so die Xbox-Mains
Haben geschrieben, ja, bei uns geht alles
So
Und da kamen gleich die Playstation-Fanboys an
Anstatt sich aufzuregen irgendwie
Dass das ihren Online-Dienst nicht angeht
Nicht ging, kam es dann an
Oh fuck, Xbox, bei euch kostet das im Monat was
Da habe ich lieber Ausfälle
Sony beste, fuck Microsoft
So richtig komplett weltfremd irgendwie
Als würde irgendwie eine Firma
Was auf so Fanboy-Geschiss überhaupt geben
Ja
Das ist gefundenes Vieh zum Melken letztendlich
Ähm...
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn
Eine Firma so extrem zu fanboyen
Gibt's nicht
Egal ob das AMD ist, ob das AMD Nvidia ist
Ob das AMD Intel ist
Ob das Microsoft Sony ist
Ob das, was gibt's da noch alles
Gibt's zig, zigtausend Sachen, ja
Es ist das dümmste, was man machen kann
So, so, so den, so irgendwie einen Hersteller
Auf Teufel komm raus verteidigen
Du hast bei manchen Leute
Das Gefühl
Dass für sie, ähm
Die Frage
Ob Apple oder Microsoft
Oder, oder, ähm
Ob, ob Sony oder, oder Nintendo
Oder sowas
Das löst für die schon im Hirn so übelste Glaubenskonflikte aus, ja
Das ist das, das ist für die Leute ganz schlimm
Und wenn dann irgendwie einer was sagt
Ähm, berechtigterweise
Über seine Konsole, über seinen Hersteller oder sonst was
Berechtigterweise
Flippen die voll aus
Da flippen die voll aus
Ich mein, deswegen war's ja schon mal erfrischend zu sehen
Dass auch die Apple, die Apple-Fans
Die auf der Apple-Konferenz waren
Auch mal ein bisschen doof geguckt haben
Ähm
Als es 1.000 Euro Bildschirmstand
Bildschirmfuß gegeben hat
Monitorstand
Ähm
Ja genau, Twombly
COD vs. Battlefield
Das ist, das ist unglaublich dumm
Einfach aus dem Grund
Die Hersteller scheißen da komplett drauf
Das sind die Leute
Denen die Hersteller
Nuka Cola
Collectors Edition verkaufen
Und es gibt bestimmt heute noch
Na, selbst nach dieser Fallout ähm 76
Ähm
Nach dieser Fallout 76 Geschichte
Gibt es garantiert heute noch
Die Ultra-Fallout-Fanboys
Die das Game verteidigen
100 pro
Es sind weniger geworden, ja
Aber gibt es immer noch
Gibt es, ich, ich könnte wetten
Wenn man jetzt
Wenn man jetzt auf das
Wenn man jetzt auf das Fallout-Reddit geht
Hast du immer noch
Du hast auch, du hast auch die Leute
Die irgendwie
Übelst verpackte Bethesda-Spiele
Oder so verteidigen, ja
Ähm
Da fällt, denen fällt dann immer irgendwas ein
So nach dem Motto
Und die beste
Das beste Argument ist immer noch
Mal an, also
Mal angenommen
Ich würde jetzt
Ich würde jetzt irgendwie
Auf Twitter schreiben
Keine Ahnung
Hersteller XY hat ne scheiß Webseite
Weil
Sie ist langsam
So
Irgendwas
Oder
Hersteller XY hat ne
Hat ne scheiß Webseite
Moment
Ähm
Weil
Ich Flash installieren muss ich
Ich Flash installieren muss
Hey
Das wäre ne objektive Sache
Ne
Wenn ich heute
Wenn ich im Jahr 2019 sagen kann
Hersteller XY hat ne scheiß Webseite
Weil die braucht Flash
Dann ist das finde ich relativ nachvollziehbar
Ne
Nicht so
Nicht so für die Fanboys
Die Fanboys sagen dann
Alter
Ich bin froh
Dass das Flash ist
Endlich
Hat noch ein Hersteller
Mal ne gescheite Sache
Auf seiner Webseite
Und Apple ist ja
Oder was auch immer
XY
Apple verwendet
Selbstverständlich
Kein Flash
Apple war führender daran beteiligt
Dass Flash den Bach runtergegangen ist
Aber
Wenn Flash den Bach runtergegangen ist
Die verteidigen das dann richtig
Und wenn den Leuten gar nichts mehr einfällt
Den super
Super krassen Fanboys
Dann kommt
Dann kommt das
Das Totschlagargument für die schlechthin
Da kommt dann als Antwort
Mach du erst mal ne bessere Webseite
Denk ich mir da auch immer
Ah
Huge brain
Huge
Muss
Massive sein
Mach erst mal ne bessere Webseite
Dann kannst du meckern
Also sprich
Wenn ich sage
Also
Ich hab mir jetzt ne Playstation gekauft
Und ich find's irgendwie kacke
Dass das PSN so oft weg ist
Rein theoretisch gesehen
Ist es jetzt
Aber
Rein theoretisch gesehen
Ist es ja auch gar nicht
Ähm
Dann sagen dann die Sony Fanboys nicht
Ja
Es wär schon schön
Wenn das
Wenn das mehr online wäre
Die sagen dann
Nein
Geh zurück zu deiner Fickbox
Oder sowas
Also
So ne umgedrehte
Umgedrehte Antwort
Oder so
Oder so nach dem Motto
Ja
Dann programmier du das doch erst mal besser
Als die Jungs von Sony
Das wird schon seinen Grund haben
Oder sowas
Ach
Da könnt
Also diese
So ein Wort für
So diese
Diese White Knight Geschichte
Die Corporate White Knight
Geschichte
Das ist so unglaublich dumm
Egal
So als ist mir nur gerade eingefallen
An der Stelle
Wo er davon geredet hat
Großer Intel Fanboy
Da kommen dann immer wieder so
Ist das eigentlich laut genug?
Wir müssen ein Stückchen lauter machen
Vielleicht müssen wir auch einfach mal gucken
Kommentare wie dieser hier
Von Icebox
Könnt ihr euch dann
In Ruhe durchlesen
Könnt ihr das Video pausieren
Oder
Wir pausieren jetzt das Video
Und lesen uns das mal durch
Weil wahrscheinlich
Ist das so ein Typ
Okay
Das ist wahrscheinlich typischer
Fanboy
Ha
Es sollte doch vollkommen verständlich sein
Dass eine neue CPU Architektur
Anfangs problem macht
Ja gut
Geil
Finden muss man es
Trotzdem nicht
Das war
Bisher immer so
Und betrifft AMD
Wie Intel
Das ist auch richtig
Es sollte also Klar sein
dass künftige bios version
erst das volle potential
Letztendlich
Blablabla
Vor allem
Betrifft dieaveien
Weil er ja auch noch selbst sagt, ich finde immer Kommentare geil, die so tun, die das unter einem Video von jemandem schreiben und so tun, als wäre derjenige, der das Video gemacht hat, gar nicht anwesend.
Was hat das denn damit zu tun? Das ist wieder so ein richtig dummes Comment.
Man merkt halt immer wieder, dass Roman nie ein Freund von AMD war und lieber die Intel-Prozessoren bevorzugt.
Hey, weil er sagt, dass das BIOS noch nicht ausgereift ist. Wenn das BIOS nicht ausgereift ist, dann hat er recht.
Warum sollte man das nicht sagen? Man kann sogar übelste AMD-Fan sein und sagen, ey, Leute, aktuell würde ich es mir noch nicht kaufen, weil BIOS nicht ausgereift ist. Wo ist das Problem?
Unten steht dann wieder, man merkt halt immer wieder, dass Roman noch nie ein Freund von AMD war, lieber Intel-Prozessoren bevorzugt, lieber lästert.
Dann hier von Ronny, wie alle die Dinger loben, nur der Intel-Fanboy hier.
Das ist typische.
Also dieses typische Fanboy-Kommentar, sowas, ey.
Da kriege ich Anfälle bei sowas. Das hat mich auch bei COD und Battlefield-Videos immer übelst genervt.
Genau so Typen gehen mir echt auf den Keks hier. So wie der Ronny-Hilfe-Kerl.
Oh nein, ich installiere kein Mist nur für eine CPU.
Hä? Was will er uns sagen?
Irgendwie noch seine Intel-CPUs loswerden will.
Was?
Deutsch. Nicht vorhanden.
Dann Carsten. Oh mein Gott, ein Intel-Fanboy bringt News zu AMD. Respekt.
Only an Intel-Shield could be disappointed by Ryzen 3000. LOL.
Why is it every video the Bauer does on an Intel?
Wir haben uns doch das Video von ihm angeguckt zu AMD. Der hat AMD doch überhaupt nicht geflamed oder so?
Das war doch ein vollkommen anständiges, normales Video.
Ich weiß gar nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die Leute für Probleme haben, ey.
Ein AMD-Produkt, he has to trash it. He's a truly Intel-Fanboy.
Der Kommentar, den fand ich...
Wenn hier einer Fanboy ist, dann auch der.
Da muss ich schon sagen, da muss ich schon lachen.
Everything is good. Background, content, all good, except this person.
Das ist halt YouTube. Das ist halt YouTube, ey.
Jetzt mal, um zum Thema zurückzukommen.
Generell ist mein Kanal eben sehr kritisch gegenüber vielen Themen.
Ich mache generell sehr selten Reviews, die einfach nur so Performance betrachten, die Spiele-Performance betrachten und dann sagen, okay, geil, die...
Fraulein, genau das ist es.
Genau das ist es.
Das habe ich auch immer in den COD vs. Battlefield-Videos gesagt.
Der Fraulein hat gerade geschrieben, ich will keine Kritik über mein Produkt hören, sonst müsste mich mir eingestehen, dass ich vielleicht einen Fehlkauf gemacht habe.
Genau das ist es.
Er muss sich dafür nicht rechtfertigen, er will halt dazu was sagen.
Kann ich schon verstehen.
Genau das ist es.
Viele Leute verteidigen einfach auf Teufel komm raus das, was sie gekauft haben, weil, wenn sie nur fünf Minuten mal drüber nachdenken würden,
würden einige Leute feststellen, dass es doch nicht so die beste Idee war, was zu kaufen.
Oder die AMD-CPU ist top, sondern ich mache Content, der mich persönlich interessiert.
Alles das, was ich hier tue...
Hat er ja auch recht.
YouTube ist für mich immer noch ein Hobby.
Ich mache das hier nicht Vollzeit oder sowas.
Sondern...
Ich mache das alles aus persönlichem Interesse.
Das war bei mir schon immer so.
Ich habe mich für die ganzen Hardware-Geschichten einfach schon immer extrem interessiert.
Und deswegen interessieren mich halt auch diese ganzen ungewöhnlichen Dinge, die man so nirgends findet.
Also gerade Dinge, die im Hintergrund passieren, technische Aspekte, die man so einfach nicht findet.
Und da kann man natürlich auch schnell einen falschen Eindruck bekommen, was ich gut verstehen kann.
Das liegt gerade, wenn man über die AMD-Intel-Thematik spricht, vor allem daran,
weil AMD sehr viel Angriffsfläche bietet.
Das muss man ganz klar sagen.
AMD hat extrem viel Marketing, sagt viel, verspricht viel.
Davon wird am Ende oft leider nicht viel gehalten.
Spätestens jetzt sind die AMD-Fanboys komplett wieder auf 180.
Das muss ich leider so sagen.
Das ist wie bei diesem einen Video, wo diese AMD-Frequency-Curves gezeichnet wurden.
Also diese Kurven.
Von dem Ryzen 3000, wo dann gesagt wurde, ja, die CPU kann dann zum Beispiel auf 4,75 GHz boosten.
Ich bin bei solchen Sachen einfach, ich bin einfach kein Freund von solchen Dingen.
Weil das löst in uns allen falsche Versprechen aus.
Dann erwartet man viel und bekommt es aber nicht.
Und das mag ich einfach nicht.
Das muss ich einfach persönlich sagen.
Intel gegenüber hat einfach ein absolut katastrophales Marketing.
Oder haben die überhaupt ein Marketing?
Die haben nix da, der hat recht.
Die haben das Einzige, was...
Wann habt ihr zuletzt mal Intel?
Intel-Werbung gesehen, das ist ganz selten.
Intel ist einfach da.
Und Intel war die letzten, sagen wir mal, 10 Jahre einfach...
Du bist halt nicht an Intel vorbeigekommen.
Das Einzige, was ich von Intel sehe, ist, dass sie ab und zu mal irgendwelche CS
oder irgendwie Intel Extreme Masters oder irgendwelche E-Sport-Geschichten sponsoren.
Dann gibt es ab und zu mal irgendwie sowas, was für super krasse Dudes sie sind.
Aber ansonsten...
Also Intel hat wirklich wenig, da hat er schon recht.
Aber Intel hat es ja auch eigentlich nicht nötig irgendwo, die letzten 10 Jahre gehabt.
Auf jeden Fall bieten die, weil sie einfach kein Marketing haben oder keine Ahnung, mir fällt da nie was auf, weil da nichts existiert,
natürlich dementsprechend gegenüber AMD wenig Angriffsfläche.
Also ich kann AMD oder ich kann Intel-Marketing schlecht zerstören, wenn es keins gibt.
Da muss man sagen, Intel-Marketing, weiß ich nicht.
Das ist für mich auch eine absolute Katastrophe.
Und dementsprechend, wenn natürlich dann AMD sowas sagt und ich kann darauf eingehen, ist das auch ein Problem.
Bin mir klar, dass es einem dann so vorkommt, dass sie nicht nur gegen AMD schießen, aber Intel hat einfach kein Marketing,
macht die ganze Sache nicht besser.
Und wenn wir einfach mal so betrachten was ich in der Vergangenheit für Content gemacht habe
Ich wollte übrigens mal was mit Intel machen, habe ich das schon mal erzählt.
Das ist aber schon ein bisschen her.
Und im Endeffekt ist es dann nicht zustande gekommen, weil sie irgendwie nicht wussten was sie machen wollen.
Das war auch Huge-Brain, das trifft es eigentlich genauso, wie er das sagt.
Im Dezember 2018
habe ich eine Analyse
vom Z390 Socket gemacht. Da habe ich gezeigt, dass die aktuellen CPUs 9900K auch problemlos
mit der Hälfte von den Pins laufen. Das heißt, die wären auch abwärtskompatibel gewesen
zu Z170. Und das könnt ihr mir glauben, ist etwas, was mich auch nicht gefallen hat.
Oder jetzt neuerdings. Falscher Sound, eigentlich wollte ich den hier abspielen.
Oktober 2018 habe ich ein Video zum 9900K gemacht, den geköpft, als der neu auf den Markt kam.
Oh ja, das habe ich geguckt. Das ist das Video, wo ich mir abgeguckt habe, wie man
einen 8700K köpft, bevor ich meinen geköpft habe.
Wird sehr warm. Und dann habe ich eben analysiert, warum das so ist und Intel oder die Art wie
Intel...
Und er hat damals auch gesagt, ich kenne das Video noch, er hat damals auch gesagt, wie
scheiße das ist, dass Intel den Kram nicht verlötet. Und damals haben sich wahrscheinlich
alle aufgeregt. Alter, kack, kack AMD Fanboy oder sowas. Und jetzt ist es umgedreht. So
hängen geblieben.
Wenn man die CPU verlötet, ist es halt so, wenn man die köpft, dann holt man halt trotzdem
8-9 Grad raus.
Auch das hat Intel nicht gefallen. Das könnt ihr mir glauben.
August 2018 habe ich 8 Videos gebracht zum Thema Epic Overclocking. Ein Thema, was mir
persönlich sehr viel Spaß gemacht hat.
Alter, was ist das da unten? Sieht aus wie auf irgendwie, wie in so einem Freizeitpark
so eine Wasserrutsche oder so.
Nicht so sehr, weil die natürlich nicht wollten, dass man AMD, Epic oder Server CPUs
übertaktet. Leider wurde dem Ganzen auch ein Riegel vorgeschoben. Also diese Sicherheitslösung
die wir genutzt haben.
Fuck, was ist das? Ist das flüssig? Ist das hier wieder Stickstoff oder was ist das? Oder
was macht der da?
Also keine Sicherheitslücke, aber die Lücke, die wir genutzt haben, um die Epic CPUs zu
übertakten, die wurde leider geschlossen. Also bei den kommenden CPUs ist das so leider
nicht mehr möglich.
Ein Strömungstest, okay.
Dann April 2018 habe ich Zen Plus, also den 2700X geköpft. Zum Beispiel da habe ich
auch gesagt, ey, top verlötet. Lohnt sich nicht.
Okay.
Macht es nicht. Januar 2018, ein großes Thema Threadripper gegen Epic. Da war auch
wieder so, da kam das den Leuten so vor, wow, der macht so richtig krassen Content die ganze
Zeit gegen Threadripper. Angefangen hat dieses ganze Thema nur, ich hatte einen Threadripper
vor Launch, nicht von AMD, aber ich hatte einen vor Launch und dann habe ich den geköpft
und dann habe ich ein Video dazu gemacht, habe AMD gefragt, ey, es ist doch nächste
Woche dieses Embargo wird aufgehoben, dass wir Unboxings zeigen dürfen. Da habe ich
gesagt, worunter fällt eine CPU köpfen? Ich zeige ja keine Leistung, ich öffne ja nur
die CPU, fällt das unter Unboxing. Sagt AMD zu mir, ja, kannst du posten. Poste ich das
Video, ein Tag später schreibt mir AMD, dieses Video muss sofort offline.
Das ist so geil, das hast du öfters, dass die nicht genau wissen. Also ich weiß nicht,
wie es Standard ist bei AMD, aber so hin und her hatte ich damals auch bei, das muss ich
ein bisschen ausholen, EA hatte damals die erste Iteration.
Diese Iteration ihrer Creator Plattform, Ronku hieß das damals. Und da waren sie sich mit
den Regeln für ihre Videos auch teilweise nicht so ganz einig.
So, wenn man da viel Zeit rein investiert und auch Geld in solche Videos und dann, wenn
nur ein Teil der quasi Views entstanden ist und man wird gezwungen, das offline zu nehmen,
während alle anderen Medien das schon aufgegriffen haben, sich das im Internet verteilt, dann
ist das natürlich total dämlich, das Video offline zu nehmen. Muss sich dann aber trotzdem
aufnehmen.
Und dann kam dann zum Beispiel von AMD ein Statement, weil ich hatte dann gesagt, okay,
hier sind vier Chips drauf auf den Threadripper CPUs, deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich technisch
identisch zu Epic. Oder es kommt halt entweder noch ein 32k Threadripper, weil es gab einfach
technisch gesehen keine andere logische Erklärung. Warum sollte man vier Chips drauf machen,
wenn man die Hälfte davon quasi verschwendet? Die einzige logische Erklärung war, es ist ein
32k Threadripper. Kam AMD Statement, nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper. Dann kam AMD Statement,
nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper. Dann kam AMD Statement, nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper. Dann
kam AMD Statement, nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper. Dann kam AMD Statement, nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper.
Dann kam AMD Statement, nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper. Dann kam AMD Statement, nein, es ist ein
32k Threadripper. Dann kam AMD Statement, nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper. Dann kam AMD Statement,
nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper. Dann kam AMD Statement, nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper.
Dann kam AMD Statement, nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper. Dann kam AMD Statement, nein, es ist ein 32k Threadripper.
die haben keine Schaltkreise drauf, die sind Dummies.
Da dachte ich mir, macht keinen Sinn.
Also wo wir wieder bei dem Thema wären, Marketing, das keinen Sinn ergibt.
Dann habe ich das aufgegriffen, habe ein Video dazu gemacht,
habe die Chips analysiert, habe gesehen, okay, es sind Schaltkreise drunter,
es muss ein 32-Kern-Viertel überkommen.
Was ist passiert? Halbes Jahr später kam ein 32-Kern-Viertel über.
Aber erst mal so hinstellen, als wären meine Aussagen falsch.
Diese Dinge sind einfach natürlich Sachen,
ich fühle mich dadurch jetzt nicht persönlich angegriffen oder sowas,
aber es macht mir natürlich unheimlich Spaß,
dann darauf einzugehen und damit zu spielen.
Könnt ihr wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo nachvollziehen.
Zum Beispiel August 2016, das ist ein bisschen weiter zurück,
habe ich ein Video gemacht, wo ich die NVIDIA High-Bandwidth-SLI-Brücke analysiert habe.
Da habe ich mir angeschaut, wie sieht so eine NVIDIA High-Bandwidth-SLI-Brücke aus.
Man braucht, wozu soll das gut sein?
Entweder ist das SLI und das funktioniert,
oder es funktioniert nicht.
Machen wir eine echte High-Bandwidth-Bridge, was auch immer.
Die SLI-Brücke aus, also die kam ja vor NV-Link.
Da wurde gesagt, okay, es gibt jetzt diese neuen High-Bandwidth-SLI-Brücken,
die können viel mehr Daten übertragen,
die sind technisch viel aufwendiger als normale SLI-Brücken und so weiter.
Dann habe ich da Röntgenanalysen machen lassen von den SLI-Brücken
und habe quasi gezeigt, dass die SLI-Brücken genauso sind wie vorher
und einfach nur so ein paar zusätzliche Sachen drin haben.
Genau das habe ich mir gedacht.
Es gab was.
Es hat NVIDIA dafür, meine ich, gefallen.
Dann der Klassiker.
Das war im Juni 2017 kam das X299 VRM-Desaster-Video.
Eines meiner kritischsten Videos, das ich je gemacht habe.
Kritisch auch in der Hinsicht, weil ich dadurch sehr, sehr viele Kontakte zerstört habe.
Ihr müsst bedenken, ich habe in dem Video gesagt,
dass bei der X299-Plattform die Spannungswandler bzw. die Spannungswandler-Kühler so extrem unterdimensioniert sind,
dass Overclocking, so wie das vorgesehen ist, wie es beworben wird von Mainboard-Herstellern, nicht möglich ist.
Und das Ganze war ein Resultat aus mehreren Jahren, die sich zusammengetragen haben.
Denn es war schon so, bei Z170, bei Z97 und sogar bei X99 hatte ich diese Probleme schon festgestellt.
Habe das an die Hersteller übermittelt, hauptsächlich an Asus und an Gigabyte.
Und es hat sich damals nichts getan.
Es wurde von den Herstellern, es kamen so Aussagen wie,
okay, wir wissen, dass die Probleme existieren, die Spannungswandler werden warm,
aber die Designs sehen halt so besser aus, als wenn wir da so Finden drauf machen.
Ich habe zwei Jahre lang da quasi gegen Wendy geredet und bei X299 war das Problem für mich...
Ich meine, wenn ein Mainboard 360 Quickscope Killer HD Pro Gamer Edition heißt,
Brain Booster Pro Gamer Edition,
dann muss das natürlich auch erst einmal gut aussehen und erst im zweiten Schritt funktionieren.
So kritisch, oder was ich gesehen habe, dass ich dann da quasi ein öffentliches Statement-Video dazu gemacht habe,
damit sich etwas ändert.
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, ich war sehr lange oder ich bin schon sehr lange in dieser Branche aktiv,
schon 15 Jahre circa.
Ich habe sehr viele Freunde in der Industrie und sehr viele haben sich da auch auf die Füße getreten gefühlt,
als ich dieses Video veröffentlicht habe.
Ich war zum Beispiel ein halbes Jahr vorher bei Intel im Headquarter in den USA und Intel hat mir danach zum Beispiel gesagt,
dass nach diesem X299-Video,
werde ich nie wieder irgendwo von Intel eingeladen,
ich darf nie wieder zu Intel in das Headquarter rein und so weiter.
Also ich habe meinen kompletten Intel-Kontakt quasi abgebrannt dafür, um dieses Video zu machen.
Und auch die Mainboard-Hersteller waren danach sehr reserviert mir gegenüber.
Ich habe am nächsten Tag sehr viele Anrufe bekommen von den Herstellern und haben gesagt,
wir wissen nicht, ob wir mit dir in der Zukunft nochmal irgendwas machen können.
Und das war für mich, das war mir klar, als ich dieses Video gemacht habe.
Mir war komplett bewusst,
wie die Resonanz von so einem Video sein wird.
Ich zeige euch mal was.
Genau die gleiche Erfahrung habe ich auch gemacht.
Wobei es bei mir nicht darauf rausgelaufen ist, dass...
Egal.
Vielleicht kennt noch einer dieses Video hier.
Von 2013.
Da habe ich Activision übelst geflamed.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, wegen was.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen habe ich Activision geflamed.
Wenn ihr wollt, können wir uns das dann nochmal anhören.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe fünf Minuten Activision geflamed.
Ähm...
Und...
Das...
Danach hat auch der damalige Community Manager von Activision in Deutschland,
der war neu, der hat gesagt,
also wenn ich will, dass ich nochmal irgendwohin eingeladen werde
oder dass ich in Zukunft eingeladen werde
oder dass er mich jetzt auch einladen kann,
muss ich das Video löschen.
Also die sind da schon hinterher, ja.
Ich habe das Video natürlich nicht gelöscht.
Und das hat danach trotzdem funktioniert.
Aber das ist nicht ohne, ja.
Und man muss sich auch mal überlegen, das ist schon ein gewisses Risiko.
Ich meine, wenn du ein Kanal bist, der, sagen wir jetzt mal,
sich auf spezielle Games spezialisiert hat
oder auf Hardware-Geschichten spezialisiert hat,
dann profitierst du natürlich auch extrem davon,
wenn du einen guten Kontakt zum Hersteller hast
und wenn du vielleicht auch die ein oder anderen Sachen eben schon...
dann sehr zeitig hast.
Weil umso früher du bist, umso mehr Leute gucken das Ganze.
Ist ja logisch irgendwo.
Auf der anderen Seite ist es für dich auch wieder blöd,
weil du hast immer das Gefühl, du kannst nicht komplett sagen, was du willst.
Und es gibt Channels, nehmen wir mal jetzt irgendwie...
Nehmen wir mal irgendwie einen Overwatch-Channel, ja.
Nehmen wir mal zum Beispiel, weil ich immer auf Twitter folge,
Highscore Heroes zu machen.
Der hat mit Sicherheit einen ziemlich guten Grad zu Blizzard
und macht hauptsächlich Overwatch-Content oder anderen Blizzard-Content.
Wenn der jetzt ein Video machen würde,
und das merkt man auch in den Videos,
dass gerade auch berechtigterweise Leute halt daran recht reserviert sind,
was sich ins Rückhalten, was Kritik anbelangt,
dann muss man sich mal überlegen, was da los wäre,
wenn du auf einmal keinerlei Support mehr von dem Hersteller hast,
dessen einziger Content auf deinem Channel quasi gebracht wird.
Das ist echt nicht zu unterschätzen.
Wollen wir das Video danach dann nochmal gucken, was ich damals geflamed habe.
Ich weiß es schon gar nicht mehr.
... so sein kann, wenn man so kritisch sich im Internet äußert,
wenn man eine gewisse Reichweite hat.
Aber aus meiner Sicht ist das manchmal eben einfach auch notwendig.
Also gerade, wenn man YouTuber ist, der jetzt...
Ich sehe mich eher nicht so als Werbemarionette,
sondern ich berichte über Dinge, die mir gefallen, die mir nicht gefallen.
Und dann muss man eben halt auch ehrlich bleiben.
Und wenn mir Dinge nicht gefallen, dann muss es eben auch gesagt werden,
weil es bringt uns allen am Herzen,
denn am Ende nichts, wenn wir das verschweigen.
Wenn alle Reviewer nur Produkte reviewen und sagen,
wow, das ist toll, kauf das, das ist toll, kauf das,
dann verbessert sich das.
Iron Jesus. Danke für den Twitch Prime Sub.
Twitch Prime Sub.
Weil ihr müsst jetzt mal zurück überlegen,
2017 habe ich diese ganze VRM-Thematik angesprochen.
Oh, die FPS, danke schön.
Danach kam das auf, dass dann alle Reviewer plötzlich gesagt haben,
oh, da gibt es ja was Interessantes, das können wir testen.
Ich habe mit allen großen Reviewern gesprochen, wie man sowas testet,
wie man die Spannungswandler analysiert und so weiter.
Jetzt geht es aber hier ab.
Quantal Quetzal, danke schön, Twitch Prime.
Big Brains hier wieder alle im Chat heute.
Und schaut euch an, was ich getan habe.
Was ist denn jetzt los hier?
Thais123, Twitch Prime, danke schön.
Übrigens, falls es noch Leute gibt, jetzt muss ich mal den Sellout starten.
Falls es noch Leute gibt, nein, ich mache nicht ihn als Hintergrund,
weil das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Falls es noch Leute gibt, die keine Ahnung haben,
was diese ganze Twitch Prime-Geschichte ist,
denen kann ich das natürlich mal kurz erklären.
Wenn man einen Amazon Prime-Account hat,
kann man diesen Amazon Prime-Account kostenlos mit Twitch verknüpfen
und kann dann, man kriegt dann auch komisches Prime-Loot,
habe ich noch nie eingelöst, aber das Beste daran ist,
man kann kostenlos einen Streamer seiner Wahl unterstützen mit einem Sub,
ohne dass es einen selbst was kostet.
Allerdings, der Streamer kriegt trotzdem seinen Anteil von Twitch.
Sellout-Modus beendet.
Den haben wir noch.
RIPT12 und Sobati, Twitch Prime, danke schön.
POG.
Huge POG.
Easy.
Richtig POG.
In den letzten zwei Jahren hat sich diese ganze Thematik
um die Kühllösungen extrem krass verbessert.
Heutzutage werben sogar die ganzen Mainboard-Hersteller damit und sagen,
boah, schaut euch unsere Kühllösung an,
die ist so und so viel kühler als die von der Konkurrenz.
Also wir haben jetzt genau das krasse Gegenteil von dem,
was wir 2017 haben.
Und ich will mich da jetzt nicht selber loben oder sowas,
aber das ist halt auch das Resultat von diesem Video.
Das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Und wenn wir Dinge verschweigen, die nicht funktionieren,
dann wird sich nichts verbessern.
Das stimmt.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel sage, okay, wir haben hier neue AMD-CPUs
und die erreichen den Takt nicht,
dann ist das nicht, weil ich irgendwie AMD bashen will,
sondern weil ich erreichen möchte, dass es am Ende funktioniert.
Ja, der hat voll und ganz recht.
Es hat überhaupt keinen Sinn, neues Zeug zu zeigen.
Also wie gesagt, es sei dann,
es ist jetzt halt was eingekauftes vom Hersteller letztendlich, ja.
Aber wenn es nicht nur den Anschein haben soll von was Objektivem,
sondern es ist wirklich objektiv,
dann hat wirklich außer eventuell jetzt unmittelbar der Hersteller
keiner was von, wenn man da irgendwie alles schön redet.
Weil letztendlich, was ist das Resultat?
Die Leute kaufen sich...
Stellt euch mal vor, Xbox One zu release.
Alle hätten gesagt, oh, beste...
Ihr erinnert euch ja vielleicht noch an diese MLG-Geschichte
mit Xbox damals.
Beste Konsole aller Zeiten.
Ich stelle euch vor, alle Influencer,
was ja auch jetzt, das Wort gibt es ja auch erst seit drei, vier Jahren,
alle auf YouTube und alle, alle, alle, alle, egal wo,
hätten alle gesagt, Xbox One, beste.
Und die Leute hätten sich die Xbox One gekauft
und hätten festgestellt, sie ist kacke.
Zu release zumindest.
Das wäre scheiße gewesen für die Leute,
die massig Kohle ausgegeben haben.
Und es wäre für denjenigen, der das zu sehr übertrieben hat,
auch nicht gut.
.
Vielleicht, dass Microsoft ordentlich Kohle geblecht hat dafür, ja.
Aber ansonsten, langfristig ist das, wenn man das zu oft macht
oder zu offensichtlich, ist das auch für einen Channel-Betreiber nicht gut.
Weil ich arbeite ja auch für Caseking, das wisst ihr ja alle.
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wir verkaufen da das ein oder andere PC-System.
Wenn wir einen Ryzen da verkaufen und der wird angegeben mit zum Beispiel 4,6 Gigahertz,
der kommt beim Kunden an und der macht den Takt nicht.
Ja.
Dann kann der sagen, ey, ich gebe den PC zurück,
der erreicht nicht das, was die Spezifikationen versprechen.
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, wie viele Leute bei uns im Kundencenter anrufen
und einfach nur technische Fragen haben, ey, warum boostet CPUX nicht so hoch?
Das haben wir bei Intel genauso wie bei AMD.
Gerade, weil diese ganzen Boost-Thematiken eben auch sehr, sehr undurchsichtig sind
und oft auch nicht genau erklärt wird, welche CPU in welchem Zustand,
in welcher Situation genau wie boostet.
Selbst für mich ist das oft gar nicht klar.
Gerade auch bei Intel zum Beispiel diese AVX-Offset-Thematik,
dass nicht genau klar ist, bei welcher CPU in welchem Zustand was für ein Offset zum Beispiel verwendet wird automatisch.
Und das sind solche Themen, da bin ich einfach kein Freund von,
weil das am Ende einfach Unklarheiten für uns Endkunden bewirkt.
Und ja, da haben wir nichts davon.
Deswegen müssen Dinge, die nicht passen, die aktuell nicht funktionieren,
müssen einfach ausgesprochen werden.
Das hat nichts mit persönlicher Vorliebe zu tun.
Mir ist es egal.
Und selbst wenn, wenn in dem Fall was dran ist, wo ist das Problem?
Ich hate quasi gegen jede Firma.
Das interessiert mich nicht.
Es ist mir egal, ob da Intel, Nvidia, AMD draufsteht.
Das spielt für mich keine Rolle.
Weil, warum?
Ich bin mit keiner von den Firmen irgendwie persönlich verbunden.
Ich habe keinen Vorteil davon, wenn die eine Firma mehr verkauft als die andere.
Das ist mir persönlich komplett egal.
Mir geht es einfach nur darum, dass das, was wir kaufen, so gut wie möglich funktioniert.
Wenn wir Verbesserungsoptionen haben,
wenn wir Verbesserungspotenzial sehen,
dann sollten wir das auch immer sagen und dafür sorgen,
dass sich auch Dinge ändern, wenn sie nicht funktionieren.
Interessanterweise bekomme ich zum Beispiel auch von den meisten Herstellern
gar keine Samples zur Produktlaune.
Also AMD und Intel, die schicken mir nie irgendwas.
Bei denen bin ich quasi gefühlt auf so einer Blacklist.
Und ich mache dieses Video auch, weil, als ich mit AMD gesprochen habe letzte Woche,
da hat auch AMD gemeint, dass ich so richtig gegen AMD eingestellt wäre.
Und dann habe ich denen auch gesagt, das ist,
für mich ist das ein rein wissenschaftliches Thema.
Genau, macht es gescheit, dann muss ich euch nicht flamen.
Ist doch ganz einfach.
Wenn die CPU boostet, dann ist es für mich gut.
Wenn die eine Lösung haben, dann zeige ich die gerne.
Dann möchte ich das euch allen zeigen, wie das Ganze hinzubiegen ist.
Was, MW Fanboy, was zum Teufel hat denn bitte schon Bill Gates heute noch mit Windows zu tun?
Wie wir das Ganze gefixt bekommen.
Und nicht mal Ballmer hat mehr was mit Windows zu tun.
Und nicht mal der Windows-Dude von früher,
ich weiß nicht, wie er hieß, hat mehr was mit Windows zu tun.
Also, das hat für mich keinerlei persönliche Hintergründe.
Eigentlich ist es immer schade, dass man so ein Video überhaupt machen muss.
Ja, Cooper, ich bin auch MSI-gebannt.
Und sich da quasi so rechtfertigen muss, aber, ja.
Ich wollte das Ganze mal so ein bisschen loswerden.
Ich hoffe, ich habe euch mit dem Video nicht zu sehr gelangweilt.
Und übrigens, was dieses Ganze, was meine Getränkesituation immer betrifft.
Ja, aber er hat recht, jetzt ist es vollkommen richtig.
Vollkommen richtig.
Und weil irgendjemand gesagt hat, EA müsste ja schon längst pleite sein,
wenn die das schon eine Weile praktiziert haben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch mal den EA-Aktienkurs so angeguckt habt.
Also, EA wird nicht demnächst pleite gehen, ja.
Weil der Aktienkurs ja auch direkt damit, ob diese Firma pleite geht oder nicht,
erstmal nicht direkt was zu tun hat.
Aber auch so wird EA nicht in nächster Zeit pleite gehen.
Aber guckt euch mal das an, hier.
Guckt euch mal die EA-Aktie an.
Also, die ist jetzt nicht gerade, die ist jetzt nicht gerade so toll mehr seit ein paar Jahren.
Die ist ordentlich runtergegangen.
Ne, erstmal hier, vlup.
Und dann zu dieser, ich würde mal sagen, das war so ein bisschen auch, wann war denn das hier?
18, das war Battlefront.
Battlefront.
Und bei Battlefront ging es dann weg.
Spielen.
Nein.
Warum erkennt das mein Adblocker nicht?
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt nochmal mein Activision Flame Video an von 2013 an.
100.000 Aufrufe, 8500 Likes und 156 Dislikes.
Okay, da muss was dran.
Da muss was dran gewesen sein, was ich damals erzählt habe.
Okay, hören wir uns das mal an.
Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr, um was es ging.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist das Video, wo ich gefragt wurde, beziehungsweise quasi, dass ich es löschen soll.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max von Activision.
Versteht man alles?
Bisschen leise, gell?
... und schafft es ja immer wieder, nicht nur auf ihre Spieler zu reagieren.
Oh, oh, es geht schon gleich los.
Der Flame geht gleich los.
Ich mach mal ein Stückchen lauter.
... Mädels, hier ist der Max und Activision schafft es ja immer wieder, nicht nur auf ihre Spieler zu scheißen, sondern auf ihre Spieler zu scheißen und danach noch drauf zu pissen.
Also so diese Kombination, das haben die ja richtig gut drauf.
Also wer es nicht ertragen kann, dass ich jetzt ein bisschen hier...
Es gibt ja manche Leute, die flippen dann aus und meinen, sie müssen aus dem Fenster springen, wenn ich hier ein bisschen rumflame.
Zumindest kommt mir das teilweise so vor.
Die sollen am besten gleich ausmachen, denn ich werde mich in diesem Video ein bisschen über Activision auslassen.
Ich habe ja einen News-Beitrag gelesen bei Call of Duty Series.de.
Übrigens ganz coole Seite, guckt es euch mal unten an.
Ist die News verlinkt und zwar geht es um Booster.
Ich habe mir gedacht, ja, Booster ist ja nichts wildes.
Booster, Scheiß-Booster, Booster sind Kacke.
Ich glaube, da sind wir uns alle einig, dass Booster Kacke sind.
Ich war auch voll aufgeregt in dem Video, ey.
Was ist da los?
Nachdem jetzt natürlich Call of Duty Ghosts noch nicht so wirklich lange auf dem Markt ist...
Ghosts.
... ist ja zumindest die PC-Version und auch die Konsolen-Version teilweise offen wie ein Scheunengut.
Da wird gehackt, geboostet, sonst was.
Irgendwie, dass irgendjemand dem ganzen Einhalt gebietet.
Ja, das war doch so.
Und wir haben jetzt natürlich das schöne Pair-to-Pair-Hosting-System.
Ich meine Dedicated Server for all platforms, wir wissen es ja.
Was macht ihr denn, wenn ihr zufällig in eine Booster-Lobby kommt,
wo man für jeden Kill 3 Milliarden Punkte kriegt und auf einmal seid ihr maximal errangt?
So, dann verlasst ihr das Spiel natürlich, weil ihr euch denkt, Scheiße, ich will das nicht.
Problem ist, das Spiel speichert es.
Und jetzt, jetzt seid ihr auf die Gnade von Activision angewiesen,
dass Activision euch nicht für das wissentliche Joinen einer Booster-Lobby bannt.
Allen Ernstes, was um alles in der Welt denken die sich?
Es ging darum, irgendjemand, den genau dieser Fall betroffen hat, sprich er ist wohl...
Da hat er Recht.
Also der Max von vor fünf Jahren.
Irgendwie unglücklich in eine Booster-Lobby gekommen, hat gesagt,
Leute, könnt ihr nicht meine Stats resetten? Ich will die geboosteten Stats nicht.
Da sagt Activision, nein, wir können deine Stats nicht resetten.
Du kannst froh sein, dass wir dich nicht bannen für das wissentliche Joinen einer Booster-Lobby.
Da sagt Activision, the fuck?
Hallo?
Aber wenn das Spiel schon so kaputt ist, dass sowas tatsächlich zwei, drei Wochen nach dem Release möglich ist,
das Game ist doch nicht alt, ja?
Dass das wirklich jetzt schon möglich ist, da kann man sich doch mal ein bisschen kooperativer zeigen.
Zumal es für Call of Duty 4 auch schon ein Tool gibt, mit dem man Stats resetten kann, ja?
Und das nächste ist, sie erzählen einem nochmal, sie sind nicht dafür verantwortlich.
Selbstverständlich sind sie nicht dafür verantwortlich, ihr Spiel sauber zu halten.
Nein, man soll sich im Vorfeld bitte angucken.
Wem man denn joint, ja?
Man soll nur...
Das stimmt, das haben die damals wirklich erzählt, ne?
Ich erinnere mich da noch dran.
Das haben die damals wirklich erzählt, so nach dem Motto, ja, dann joine halt einfach keiner Booster-Lobby.
...Leuten joinen, denen man vertraut.
Der geile Witz an der ganzen Sache ist, ja, dedicated servers on all platforms, wir wissen es ja, P2P-Hosting, du hast keinen Einfluss drauf, wem du joinst, ja?
Das einzige, was du machen kannst, ist dann Call of Duty abzuschießen, danach in der Hoffnung, es speichert die Stats nicht, ja?
Also, die schaffen es regelmäßig, mit solchen Posts nicht nur auf die Leute zu scheißen, sondern echt nochmal so richtig draufzupässen.
Anstatt jetzt zu sagen, Leute, okay, das Spiel ist halt einfach verhackt, verboostet, versonstwas.
Allerdings, wer seine Stats resetet haben will, wer nicht wirklich wissentlich boosten wollte, der kann seine Stats reseten.
Nein, das machen sie nicht. Das auf gar keinen Fall, ja?
Also, Leute, ich weiß nicht, lest euch mal diese News vor.
Die ganzen Antworten, die Typen da posten, das ist echt, ich weiß manchmal echt nicht, was ich zu der ganzen Scheiße sagen soll.
Ich halte es manchmal einfach nicht aus.
Irgendwie kriege ich das nicht in meinen Kopf rein.
Eigentlich würde man ja erwarten, dass sie so ein bisschen auch noch, so ein bisschen, so ein ganz kleines bisschen, so ein bisschen auch Sympathie machen wollen, aber gar nicht, null.
Überhaupt keine Chance, ja?
Vor allem, der größte Witz dabei ist ja auch noch, dass sie ja nochmal betonen,
so schön, ja, so nach dem Motto, ist doch schön, wir könnten dich ja auch gleich bannen.
Ja.
Sei doch froh, dass du deinen Account jetzt nicht mehr gebrauchen kannst. Du kannst das Game ja nochmal kaufen vielleicht, ja?
Meine Güte, ey, ich, ups, ich packe es nicht. Na gut.
Es hat keinen Sinn, sich da weiter darüber aufzuregen.
Lest euch diese News mal durch und bildet euch da selbst ein Urteil drüber.
Ich finde es echt, ich finde es einfach hart, ja?
Hätten sie es so gemacht wie in MW3, da konnte man sich ja irgendwie mit diesen Prestige-Tokens sogar noch irgendwie resetzen.
Die News gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich behaupte einfach mal, die meisten Leute, die das spielen, die wollen nicht boosten, ja?
Wenn jemand das Game spielt, dann die meisten, die allermeisten, wollen das wirklich ordnungsgemäß durchspielen.
Und was kann denn bitteschön ein Neuling dafür, ja?
Mal irgendjemand, der das Spiel gerade gekauft hat, er joint, er macht Matchmaking, sonst was, joint irgendwo rein, ist in der Lobby und er landet zufällig als erstes in der Booster-Lobby.
Das checkt der doch gar nicht, das weiß der doch überhaupt nicht, das kann der gar nicht wissen.
Und dann sagt Activision, na, Pech gehabt, dumme Sau, hast du das Game gekauft, es ist uns scheißegal, was du damit machst.
Ja, das ist schon geil, oder?
Da ist was dran.
Ich bin echt mal dafür, dass dieses Jahr nicht EA den Worst-Company-Award kriegt, sondern echt Activision.
Das sind solche Meldungen, ich könnte echt meinen Kopf nehmen und einfach die ganze Zeit auf die Tastatur schlagen mit meinem Kopf.
Wobei das eigentlich bescheuert wäre für die Idioten, das zu machen, oder? Wenn man mal ganz ehrlich ist.
Also, ich packe es nicht.
Anstatt echt ein bisschen kooperativ zu sein.
Ja, das stimmt, aber das könnte ich heute immer noch so unterschreiben.
Und am besten noch drauf gekotzt auf die Leute, die das Game gekauft haben.
Jetzt geht er ab, ey.
Meine Fresse, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss.
Ja, aber das könnte ich heute immer noch so unterschreiben.
Da war der Max richtig am Hate-Speechen, hm?
Macht der eigentlich noch Videos hier?
Macht der noch Videos?
Hey, nice, immerhin.
Wenigstens einer von denen, die ich noch nicht damals geguckt hab, macht noch Witz.
Der ist aktiver als ich, das stimmt.
Ich hab's grad gesehen, der hat's immerhin auf drei Videos im Jahr geschafft.
Ach ja.
Da ging er ab, hä?
Da ging er ab.
Ich hab ja mehr so Videos damals noch über COD gemacht, wo ich mich übelst aufgeregt hab.
Das war auch, das war, wisst ihr, das war meine Hater-Fanboy-Zeit.
Also die Zeit, wo ich mir eigentlich gewünscht habe, dass COD wieder richtig gut wird.
Aber ich die aktuellen COD-Ausgaben richtig kacke fand.
Und nach, nach zwei, drei Jahren war's bei mir dann so, dass mir egal war.
Hat mich nicht interessiert.
Ja, ähm, erst mal Regensounds wieder anmachen.
Regensounds.
Okay, Leute.
Das Benachrichtigungs-Popup ist richtig nervig.
Was für ein Benachrichtigungs-Popup?
Wessen YouTube-Kanal war das gerade?
Ja, meiner.
Der Sander macht auch noch Videos, ja?
Ach so, das.
Ja, das ist, das ist, das ist ultra nervig.
Ich würd, ich würd auch gern einstellen, dass die Seite einfach defaultmäßig mir Seite keine Benachrichtigung schicken darf.
Der Host von gestern war richtig gut.
Der Typ macht richtig geile Videos.
Ja, ich hab auch noch ein bisschen geguckt danach.
Ist wirklich gut gewesen.
Ja, genau.
Ich bin, ich bin immer noch, äh, MSI Blacklist gebannt.
Äh, Nvidia Partner-Programm, falls du das kennst.
Ich kenn das Nvidia Partner-Programm nicht.
Ähm, ich war vor ein paar Jahren mal bei Nvidia in München.
Für die, was damals, damals wollten sie Shield, Shield und Shield-Tablet promoten.
Ähm, aber das Nvidia Partner-Programm kenn ich nicht.
Kennst du dich mit, dich mit Jenkins-Pipelines aus?
Ich würd nicht sagen, dass ich mich damit auskenne.
Also ich hab, ich hab vor vier Jahren oder so das letzte Mal großartig was mit Jenkins gemacht.
Da hab ich für, damals hab ich noch, ähm, wie gesagt, ich hab ja schon mal erzählt,
was ich auf der Arbeit mache.
Ich hab damals versucht für unsere Software-Builds, ähm, einen Jenkins, äh, aufzusetzen, der das automatisch macht.
Der dann auch so einen, so einen Übersichts-Board hatte.
So ein bisschen, so ein bisschen wie Travis von GitHub quasi.
Ähm, als halt auf Jenkins-Basis.
Das hat auch ganz gut funktioniert.
Allerdings, mittlerweile kümmert sich jemand anderes um den Jenkins.
Bin ich jetzt auch nicht gerade böse drum.
Ach, das ist gut zu wissen.
Arte, ist das nicht schlecht.
Ist deine Klimaanlage eigentlich in deiner Heimautomatisierung drinne?
Also, dass das Ding bei einer bestimmten Hitze angeht.
Nee, das hab ich nicht eingestellt, weil, dann müsste ich, also, dass, dass ich das machen könnte,
müsste ich auch einstellen, dass es verbunden ist mit Presence Detection.
Also sprich, ist jemand daheim?
Weil das wär bescheuert, die Klimaanlage vor der Pulle anzuschmeißen.
Ähm, wenn keiner daheim ist zum Beispiel.
Ja.
Aber was ich zum Beispiel mache, ist, dass, wenn ich,
wenn ich auf dem Weg heim bin, dass es dann 10 Minuten vorher schon angeht.
Na, deswegen, da hab ich ja mein, mein, mein Location Tracking auf dem iPhone.
Ähm, war kontrovers.
Wollten nur positive Reviews, sonst fliegst du aus dem Programm raus.
Das heißt, dann schicken sie nicht und mir, ah, okay.
Aber wurde gecancelt.
Ja, wenn sowas rauskommt, dann ist das natürlich, sieht das auch nicht gut aus für den Hersteller, ne.
Ja, guck ich mir nachher mal an, Arte.
Fandest du das Design besser?
Gucken wir mal.
Ja.
Viel besser.
Ja, huge. Fast, fast 100 Subs hatte ich damals.
Ich, das fand ich viel schöner damals.
Man, man müsste es ein bisschen anpassen, dass es aktueller ist, ja.
Es ist, es ist nicht mehr so ganz zeitgemäß im Endeffekt.
Auch die Wahl der Schriftart und sowas, ja.
Also das ist nicht mehr ganz, das Postfach gibt's übrigens nicht mehr, nur mal so angemerkt, ne.
Ähm, das war viel besser, das Design.
Du konntest das, du konntest das sogar noch ordentlich customizen und es war viel, viel schöner.
Viel besser.
Ja, Emix, sag mal, ich weiß.
Das Video kann ich mich überhaupt nicht dran erinnern. Habe ich das gemacht?
Ach nee, das war The Licks.
Den Lick, den gab's ja damals auch noch, ja.
Sind Chipstüten wie DLCs.
Ach, das war der Feed auch, was man geliked hat und sowas.
Ich hatte ja mal einen Minecraft-Server, oh man, ja, stimmt.
POG.
Ja, das war was, ja.
Nice, ja.
Dein favorite COD of all time?
Black Ops 1.
Stimmt, den hatte ich in den Feature Channel drinne.
Den Niko, den Niko.
Guckt mal, damals hatte ich 100, 100k und, und der Niko hatte, hatte 39, heute hat er was?
Wie, wie viel, wie viel hat der Niko heute?
Ähm, was hat er heute?
Was hat er heute? 2,1 Millionen!
Ja, ja.
Die Rheinfels-Quelle gab's damals auch noch.
Ja, ich müsste echt mal wieder ernsthaft YouTube machen. Ich mache ja schon gefühlt seit 3, 4 Jahren nicht mehr ernsthaft YouTube.
Äh, die Facebook-Währung habe ich mir neulich angeguckt, großartig.
Mein RL-Channel, welchen RL-Channel? Ich hatte nie nen RL-Channel.
Ich hatte, ich hab nen zweiten Channel gehabt, wo ich ein bisschen, ein bisschen Blödsinn hochgeladen hab mal, ja.
Hä, Friseur-Autogramm, ja.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Die, die, die, die, meine Videos ist nicht, nicht das, was der YouTube Mainstream sich angucken will.
Da müsste ich, das müsste ich da machen.
Da müsste ich ne Mischung aus, ähm, was, was mit, mit was kannst du heute noch im Gaming-Bereich so richtig abgehen?
Entweder du bist ein ultra, richtig guter Fortnite-Spieler.
Ähm, und kannst, kannst quasi die seriöse Schiene fahren, sag man mal mit, äh, ich erklär euch, wie man gut Fortnite spielt.
Oder du bist nicht so der allzu gute Fortnite-Spieler und machst funny Minecraft, äh, funny, ähm, Fortnite-Videos.
Was auch ganz gut geht ist, du machst generell so funny Gaming-Videos mit ein paar Kollegen, die, die sich halt alle kennen und halt funny sind.
Ähm, du machst Reaction-Videos.
Da musst du die, die, die müssen dann einen gewissen, gewissen Charme haben, weil Reaction-Videos gibt's schon ganz schön viele.
Ähm, als Grill machst du einfach Boop-Cam.
Minecraft, Minecraft ist gar nicht mal so angesagt.
Ich mein, klar, es gibt große Channels, die auch viel Views mit Minecraft haben, aber so den, Minecraft ist einfach so ne Konstante in der Welt irgendwie mittlerweile.
Hätte ich früher auch nicht für möglich gehalten, aber Minecraft lockt heute jetzt auch bei nem neuen Channel.
Jetzt, ähm, auch nicht mehr instant irgendwie die Hunderttausende von, von Bildschirmen.
Was hältst du generell von Crypto-Bitcoin? Hat das, das hat auf jeden Fall ne Zukunft.
Gibt es eine Thematik, auf die du denn richtig Lust hättest, bezogen auf YouTube?
Ja, hab ich ja schon mal gesagt, ich würd gerne in Videos mehr in die Richtung machen, wo's halt um, um, nicht unbedingt rein um Games geht.
Ich würd gerne, ich würd gerne, ich hätte erst mal gerne ein ordentliches Battlefield wieder.
Ich hätte mal gerne irgendwelche Games, wo, wo ich was zu sagen kann.
Dann würd ich gerne weiterhin einfach, äh, meinen Senf zu irgendwelchen aktuellen Sachen geben.
So. Und als drittes, würd ich eigentlich gerne ein bisschen mehr Technik-Krams machen.
Jetzt nicht, nicht so super advancedes Kram, wie hier im Stream, ja, das kannst du auf YouTube nicht bringen.
Aber zum Beispiel, ein selbstgebautes 10 Gigabit NAS. So was zum Beispiel, ja, so für den Noob.
Und viele Leute werden's nicht bauen, sondern einfach, die interessiert das.
Ich, wie gesagt, mein, mein, mein, ich, ich, ich, ich zeige meinen Mini-Rack.
Der hat irgendwie 150.000 Aufrufe gekriegt.
Meinung zu Commander Krieger?
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht, was er aktuell macht.
Dazu müsste ich ja erst mal vor der Kamera rumspringen.
Aber ich find, ganz ehrlich, Deluxe Tech Tips ist die optimale Mischung aus, ähm, Technik und Entertainment,
so dass es noch den Großteil der Leute anspricht.
Machst du's komplizierter, dann, dann ist das für die meisten Leute nix.
Was der Kabu macht, weiß ich nicht.
Schon ein paar Monate nix gehört.
Ja, Reveal-Video, aber wozu soll ich das machen, ey?
Weil da kennen mich die Leute ja in Frankfurt oder sonst wo.
Hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Weißt du das noch?
Wo ich mal den Friseur besucht hab, als er noch ein bisschen mehr Videos gemacht hat
und auch regelmäßig Livestream, ähm, wo wir in Dresden rumgelaufen sind.
Da hat's, und der, der war ja aber weiter nicht so groß wie jemand, wie größere Channels auf YouTube,
wo dann, äh, random die Leute laufen gekommen sind.
In der Kantau, da hab ich keinen Nerv drauf.
Das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist morgens, wenn ich in der Bahn sitz
und überhaupt keinen Bock auf die Welt um mich drum herum hab,
dass dann irgendjemand kommt und sagt, hey Max, wie geht's?
Kenn dich von YouTube.
Das ist, das ist für mich schlecht und für den schlecht.
Für alle schlecht dann.
Gifts im Discord, reicht das Nitro für 50?
Ich dachte, Nitro muss man sich selber kaufen.
Ja, schau mal, was soll ich schauen im Discord?
Okay.
Was meinst du, Discord, was?
Nebaro, was?
Auf Discord.
Datenblitz.
Haha.
Wie nennt man Max in einem Meeting?
Serious Max.
Das fand ich mal ein guter Witz, äh.
So, und was?
Und jetzt gehen, jetzt gehen...
Ne, Gifts gehen nicht, weil ich hab doch kein, ich hab doch kein Nitro.
Per PN.
Ja.
Auf, auf Twitter oder was?
Das machen wir nachher im Stream dann.
Geh bitte mal auf die Memes im Discord und bewert sie, nee.
Ähm.
Max, warum bekommt die Schweizer Bahn es hin, eine Pünktlichkeit von 96% zu haben und die deutsche Bahn es nicht?
Also ich weiß nicht, was die, was die Schweizer, also was die besonders gut machen in der Schweiz.
Ich weiß nur, was die deutsche Bahn besonders schlecht macht.
Zum Beispiel in den letzten 10 Jahren ihr Netz verkleinern, obwohl immer mehr Leute fahren.
Was mit Sicherheit ein großer Grund ist, warum es so beschissen läuft.
reg535 sagt, ich soll ein Video machen.
10 Tipps, wie du deinen PC schneller machst.
Funktioniert wirklich.
Direkt eine Million Views.
Beste.
Zack, alle weg.
So, was, was könnte man sonst noch gucken?
Ich muss mal, ich muss mal in meine später anschauen Liste gucken, ob es da irgendwas Interessantes noch drin gibt.
Kennt ihr das?
Das gucke ich, das gucke ich auch manchmal gerne.
War das das?
Kennt ihr das?
Das ist ein Typ, der macht immer Videos über seine Ameisen.
Wo man sich eigentlich denkt, das ist übelst langweilig.
Aber es ist trotzdem unterhaltsam, sich anzugucken.
Das Novak-Kühlungsvideo vom Bauer.
EA wants to know, why it gets so much hate.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Das, EA haben vor, EA ist auch so ein typisches, so ein typischer Bullshit-Marketingladen, ne?
Vor ein paar Jahren, nachdem der Hate so richtig groß war, haben sie erzählt.
Oh ja, ihr Leute, ihr habt Recht.
Und das tut uns, wir sind auch, wir sind voll geläutert.
Und aber, wir sind jetzt Player First.
EA, Player First.
Wir werden die besten Player First.
Und das, wir haben nur unsere Spieler im Sinn.
Das hat genau zwei Wochen gehalten.
Das EA besteht auch aus sehr viel Bullshit-Marketing.
Two words that conjure some of the most intense hatred you can conjure in the gaming world.
Das ist wohl wahr.
...to the new hit tearing up the charts, surprise mechanics.
It's easy to get why people perceive them as bad.
And yet, they don't get it.
Matt Bilby, EVP of Strategic Growth at EA, says,
25 years of EA and I still struggle with the external perception that we're just a bunch of bad guys.
Wobei, das ist ein anderer Typ, als ich gedacht habe.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wer das ist.
Oh, armes EA.
Armes EA.
Wie könnten die Leute nur auf die Idee kommen, dass EA nicht die Guten sind?
Wie, wie, wie, wie können, wie können die Leute nur auf die,
ist mir vollkommen unverständlich, wie EA, das weiß ich gar nicht, wie man auf die Idee kommen könnte.
Warum bekommen sie so viel Hass?
Die, die müssen das verstehen.
Die verstehen's, die sagen nur offiziell, das verstehen's nicht.
So, we could have easily titled this,
Is EA blind?
But I think that is letting them off the hook just a little bit.
Similarly, I think it's particularly interesting that they send out this single individual person
to talk about how, even after 25 years, he struggles with the perception they're just a bunch of bad guys.
As if EA is just a bunch of guys.
As if it's just a group of humans making games and that's it.
No, no, no.
If that's genuinely Matt Bilby's feelings, I feel a bit sorry for him.
I don't know Matt Bilby.
I don't know what he's like in real life.
And if you want me to be totally honest, I don't care.
I'm never gonna know Matt Bilby.
I'm never gonna have to ask Matt Bilby not to be late to show up to something.
Matt Bilby himself might be a great guy.
I just don't know.
I don't care about his demeanor at all.
Good or bad, it's irrelevant to me.
The road to hell is paved with good intentions.
And I'm not even saying that EA has good intentions.
But when a representative of the company tells the press anything that indicates they don't understand why people don't like them
and fails to take into account that they are a massive multinational corporation
that treats its customers
like crap,
I think it just kind of goes ahead and demonstrates for everybody another reason why people don't like them.
Wenn man sich das so im Hintergrund anguckt, da kann man auch überhaupt nicht auf die Idee kommen, was man an EA nicht mag.
They don't care.
They also think that we're too stupid to understand that...
Ist genau das, ist das genau, um jetzt mal, da sind wir wieder beim Anfang vom Stream, das ist genau das.
Deswegen ist es unglaublich dumm, Firmen, oder Unternehmen muss man ja sagen in dem Fall, so extrem zu fanboyen.
Weil sie scheißen drauf.
Sie scheißen, zu 99% scheißen sie drauf.
Sie haben das überhaupt nicht verdient, sie zu fanboyen.
Als Fanboy, der fanboyt, lässt man sich einfach nur besser melden.
Es ist nicht so, dass sie ihre Fans mögen.
Die mögen ihre Fans, die sich gut melden lassen.
Deswegen ist es einfach bescheuert.
...do not equate to the entirety of an organization's actions
Ich kann Blizzard auch nicht mehr fanboyen, Online-Ritter.
Was hat denn, was hat denn Blizzard die letzten Jahre...
Egal, wir gucken erst mal das Video an.
They think that customer perception is so irrelevant, or at least so not worth talking about.
Perhaps maybe they think it's a place that they might lose ground at.
If they did discuss it, I don't know.
That when they sent Matt Bilby out to talk about things, he made a case about how well they treat their employees, as well as EA Originals.
EA ist bestimmt ein ganz toller Laden.
Also, dass EA jetzt wirklich so ein schöner Ort ist, wo alle Entwickler und alle Mitarbeiter glücklich sind, hab ich auch so meine Zweifel dran.
Äh, MX, sag mal klar, das ist alles Activision mittlerweile.
Und man merkt es auch immer mehr.
Originale Blizzard-Leute sind zum größten Teil weg.
Bei Blizzard hocken jetzt Activision, BWL, Marketing-Anzug-Leute.
Ein wundervolles Programm, dass sie Indie-Developer helfen, und so weiter und so fort.
Nun, cool, es ist großartig, dass sie diese neuen Entwickler einbringen, und dass sie sie auch als Mitarbeiter behandeln.
Aber sie legen auch auch hunderten von anderen Mitarbeitern ab.
Am liebsten im März.
Und man davon abgesehen, die supporten Indie-Developers jetzt ja auch nicht, weil sie aus reiner Nächstenliebe.
Die versprechen sich ja natürlich auch was von.
Anstatt die Mitarbeiter für andere Projekte zu erhalten,
lassen sie sie einfach ab, und holen später neue.
Die, die nicht die gleichen Anforderungen machen,
und die Mitarbeiter, die für eine längere Zeit bleiben,
ist etwas, was nicht ein exklusives Problem für die Games-Industrie ist.
Aber wir haben in der Games-Industrie schon viel gesehen.
Aber, weißt du, auch ohne...
Und Anthem hört man auf.
BioWare hatte einen verrückten Crunch für Anthem, der im Grunde wertlos war.
Ja. Fehl-Game.
Die Video-Games-Industrie ist immer mehr inundiert mit diesen turbulenten Entwicklungen,
mit diesen Zeit-Zyklus-Storys, die einfach nicht etwas sind,
in dem EA nicht involviert ist.
Und während er über EA Originals redet, hat er bemerkt,
dass, während EA Originals eine Plattform für kleinere Entwickler bietet,
die sie sonst nicht haben würde,
gibt es auch einen seltsamen Element davon,
einen, Quote-un-Quote, Weg, um sich mit Talenten an kleinere Ideen zu verbinden.
Ein Weg, um EA sogar die kleine Games-Industrie zu kontrollieren.
Das haben wir geguckt, xHele.
Das Fall of 76.
Ach, ja, da muss ich jetzt aber trotzdem was zu sagen.
Ähm, Homeworld schreibt,
und Blizzard hört auf die Community, siehe Common as WoW Classic.
Ich glaube, man gibt an der Stelle Blizzard sogar zu viel Credit,
nach dem Motto, sie hören auf die Community.
Also, verstehe mich nicht falsch, ich finde es gut,
dass für Classic WoW deutsche Server kommen.
Aber, wie man überhaupt auf die Idee kommen konnte, das nicht zu tun,
ist mir vollkommen unbegreiflich.
Es hätte ihnen eigentlich von Anfang an klar sein müssen,
dass die Leute sich das wünschen.
Und sie haben sich bewusst aus internen Gründen,
die haben sich das garantiert gut überlegt,
keine deutschen Server zu machen,
haben sie sich dafür entschieden,
eben absichtlich nicht auf das zu hören, was die Leute wollen.
Und erst nachdem der negative Aufschrei so groß war,
und auch das negative Feedback,
und wahrscheinlich auch die befürchteten finanziellen Einbußen,
so groß war, dass quasi das überwiegt hat,
erst dann hat man gesagt, man macht deutsche Server.
Ich glaube auch wieder nicht,
dass sie das so nach dem Motto aus reiner Nächstenliebe machen.
Weil sie wirklich auf die Community in dem Sinn hören,
und es ihnen was Großartiges, dass es für sie was zählt.
Früher bei Blizzard wäre ich davon ausgegangen.
Ihr müsst euch mal die alten, ohne Scheiß,
guckt euch die alten BlizzCon Pressekonferenzen an.
Das war eine komplett andere Firma.
Du hattest damals...
Overwatch-Chef hat damals auf der Bühne gestanden,
für WoW noch, 2007 oder so.
Da war ja früher...
Was war Chef bei World of Warcraft?
Irgendwie Instance-Designer-Typ oder...
Ich weiß es nicht.
Zumindest hat er was mit WoW zu tun gehabt.
Der hat auf der Bühne gestanden damals,
und hat einen Witz drüber gemacht,
dass man schlechte Spieler noch aus der Gruppe kicken kann.
Das war den Witz lustig.
Wie er das gesagt hat.
Das würde der heute eben traumlich dran denken,
sowas zu sagen.
Das würde er eben traumlich dran denken.
Blizzard ist heute deutlich mehr...
Nennen wir es mal professioneller.
In dem Sinn, dass sie sich halt so verhalten,
wie es halt alle anderen auch machen.
Die Indie-Games-Industrie.
Aber, weißt du, was auch immer.
Lass uns das ausdrücken.
Und nur glauben, dass sie ihre Mitarbeiter gut behandeln,
und dass sie großartig für die Indie-Gruppe sind,
und dass EA nicht nur versucht,
Leute aus der Indie-Gruppe zu holen,
um Teil der EA zu sein, wie sie es mit jedem Entwickler tun.
Ich weiß, dass Chef der Lead-Designer von Overwatch ist.
Ich wusste bloß nicht, was er in WoW designt hat.
Ich weiß nur, dass er auf den alten Blizzcons auf der Bühne gestanden hat
und ab und zu was über WoW erzählt hat.
Das war komplett andere Welt.
Kennt ihr den Post von Chef, wo er sich über EverQuest ausgelassen hat?
Richtig kleiner Flamer, ey.
Das hier, genau, ich glaube, das meine ich.
Die gucken uns das nicht an, die Pressekonferenz.
Das geht ein Stück.
Da erzählt er über, wie sie Raids erstellen.
In WoW.
Und das ist ein komplett anderer Vortrag,
eine komplett andere Philosophie,
hinter dem, wie sie die Games gemacht haben,
als man das heute von Blizzard sieht.
Und ich kann mir einfach das nur so erklären,
dass seit da Activision mit am Start ist,
Blizzard immer mehr und mehr durch Activision,
BWL-Anzug-Menschen ersetzt wurde.
An den wichtigen Stellen.
Sodass heute quasi von der klassischen Blizzard-Philosophie
noch recht wenig übrig ist.
Ich meine, man sieht es doch schon an diesem Mobile-Diablo.
Sieht so eine Firma aus, die auf ihre Fans hört.
Ja und nein.
Ihr habt insofern schon recht.
Das, was Blizzard qualitativ rausbringt,
von technischer Seite sind die Games top.
Da kannst du nichts sagen.
Also Blizzard-Games sind in der Regel in der Beta
schon bugfreier, stabiler und runder,
als das viele Release-Titel sind.
Aber dass man die Spiele bei Blizzard noch im Hinblick
für die Spieler macht, das glaube ich nicht mehr.
Das glaube ich auch bei Blizzard nicht mehr.
Was ist denn hier eigentlich gerade Sache?
Eigentlich haben wir uns ein Video angeguckt,
warum EA so viel gehatet wird.
Beziehungsweise EA sagt,
EA weiß nicht, warum sie so viel gehatet werden.
Und irgendwie sind wir auf Blizzard gekommen.
Ja, Online-Ritter, das ist schon in progress.
Es gehen ja sogar die Gerüchte um,
habe ich schon ein paar Mal erzählt,
dass der ehemalige Blizzard-Chef mitgegangen ist.
Da gibt es wie gesagt Gerüchte.
Ich sage es nochmal, Gerüchte.
Ich verkaufe das jetzt hier nicht, als das wäre so.
Gerüchte, dass der ehemalige Blizzard-Chef,
der ist ja zurückgetreten, vorletzte BlizzCon oder so.
Oder er hat gesagt, es ist jetzt vorbei, ich mache mich vom Acker.
Weil er einer derjenigen war, der sich hingestellt hat und gesagt hat,
Overwatch ist noch nicht ready, beziehungsweise noch nicht eSport ready.
Und das passt auch.
Overwatch ist quasi jetzt erst halbwegs ready, wenn du es so willst.
Die haben jetzt erst einen Replay-Modus.
Die haben jetzt erst ein ordentliches Queue-System.
Wahrscheinlich.
Das hat tatsächlich auch so gut funktioniert, wie ich das gesehen habe in Videos von PTR.
Und da fragt man sich, war da nicht vielleicht was dran?
Ja, der Spectator und das Observen in Overwatch ist tatsächlich im Vergleich zu CS bei weitem nicht so strukturiert.
Aber das liegt auch in der Natur vom Game irgendwo.
Egal, wir gucken jetzt mal das Video weiter.
Das stimmt.
Es wird halt gemacht, was geht, ne?
Es wird halt komplett gemacht, was geht.
Sei es was Lootboxen angeht, sei es quasi an irgendwelchen versteckten Sachen, so nach dem Motto, ähm, irgendwelche Shortcut-Packs oder was hast du denn sonst noch?
Ähm, irgendwelche Sachen, die so einen ewig langen Grind haben, dass du dann doch im Shop was kaufst.
Es wird halt ausgetestet, was geht.
Und erst, wenn das Geschrei so groß ist, wie es beispielsweise bei Battlefront 2 gewesen ist, erst dann tut sich was.
Und ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sich bei Battlefront 2 auch hauptsächlich was getan hat, weil Disney damals gesagt hat, sie wollen damit nicht mehr in Verbindung gebracht werden.
Danke für die Post.
Ja, nice.
Ähm, war das, war das der Stream ohne Hose?
Bin mir jetzt gar nicht mehr sicher.
Ne, das, ne, das war nicht der Stream ohne Hose, den ich gehostet habe, oder?
Ach nein, das war, ach ich weiß es, das war der, neu installiert, das war der, der Ryzen-PC war das.
Ah, ich weiß wieder.
Ja, weil ich hab letzt, die letzte Zeit mal einen gehostet und, ähm, als der gesagt hat, quasi so hochhost, ist er aufgestanden, hat er keine Hose an.
Nicht komplett nackig oder so.
Aber halt, keine richtige Hose.
MonkaTOS, ja.
Übrigens, falls du dich fragst hier, was ist das eigentlich für ein komischer Typ, der dich da gehostet hat, ist, ich, ich, ich mach normalerweise kein Reaction-Content.
Aber heute ist so warm, da machen, da, da gucken wir uns halt mal einfach ein paar Sachen an.
The grind mindlessly long.
Encouraging people to put money into the game's randomized gambling ecosystem that will eventually yield you a means to pass by all of that grinding.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal das Game an. Von technischer Seite kann man da wirklich nichts sagen. Das sieht richtig gut aus. Das lief auch richtig gut.
Ähm, ich kann ehrlich gesagt nicht sagen, wie gut es vom Inhalt her war. Der Eax hat's, glaub ich, relativ viel gespielt, falls er da ist.
Ähm.
Aber an sich hatte Battlefront 2 schon die Chance, ein gescheites Game zu werden.
Aber es wurde komplett verkackt. Mit dieser ganzen grind microtransaction-Geschichte.
TheSimpsonsTutor hat subscribed, dankeschön.
Na, na, na, nice.
Pock.
...a means to pass by all of that grinding. Like, oh, I don't know, maybe in Star Wars Battlefront 2, which was perhaps one of the biggest game encounters.
...which was was.
...and no one likes to be considered that. Because when a massive company considers you to be just a follower that will do whatever, they throw whatever at you.
...and that's exactly what EA does. Now, I would have to say the Star Wars Battlefront 2 lootbox controversy is possibly one of the biggest controversies I've seen the entire...
...time I've played video games, which dates back to the 1980s. I must disclose if I say something like that.
But EA has been behind some of the most interesting controversies through the years, with them talking about how friendly they are to developers.
It's a little bit ironic, because through the years they've bought a number of studios and ran them into the ground.
This goes as far back to Origin, the developer of the Ultima game, which they shut down directly after...
Allerdings...
...auch wenn man das jetzt vielleicht nicht erwartet...
...in dem Fall muss ich tatsächlich auch mal was pro EA sagen.
Es liegt nicht nur an EA. Also es liegt nicht bei allen Studios immer nur an EA, dass die geschlossen werden.
Da gibt's auch genug, die haben sich einfach übernommen. Die haben gedacht so nach dem Motto, hoch, wir sind jetzt bei EA, wir schwimmen quasi in Geld...
...und haben dann Dinge halt angefangen, die nie fertig geworden sind, oder sie haben sich einfach übernommen.
Also es ist nicht unbedingt EA immer an allem schuld, auch wenn da EA auf dem Video jetzt draufsteht.
Was ich halt richtig bitter finde, ist sowas wie bei Maxis zum Beispiel, einen SimCity rausgehauen, was garantiert nicht so entstanden ist...
...weil sich das die Designer bei Maxis so gedacht haben, sondern mit Sicherheit waren da auch Leute von EA direkt dahin...
Moment, Maxis überhaupt EA? Nicht, dass ich jetzt Blödsinn erzähle. Doch, Maxis war EA, ne?
Ist ja im Prinzip wurscht, wenn nicht EA, dann ersetzt das durch was anderem, trifft ja auch zu.
Aber ich glaube, es ist EA gewesen.
Die haben das Spiel, das letzte SimCity ja nicht so verkackt, weil sich die Designer das so überlegt haben und gedacht haben...
...ja, wir wollen eine Map, die so klein ist, wir wollen ein Spiel, was immer crasht, sonst was.
Das war Termindruck, ohne Ende wahrscheinlich, unfertige Sache released, plus dass noch auf das Gameplay und das Game an sich Einfluss genommen wurde.
Das heißt, die haben die doppelte Arschkarte. Die mussten ein kack Spiel machen, das war zu früh released wurde...
...und sie wurden danach auch noch geschlossen. Das ist doppelte Arschkarte.
Also das Entwicklerstudio hatte eigentlich die richtige Arschkarte in dem Fall.
Ist EA eigentlich größer als Blizzard?
Das ist so eine Sache, wo ich aus dem Bauchgefühl sagen würde, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Allerdings hat Blizzard WoW und WoW bringt übelst viel Kohle.
Allerdings insgesamt würde ich immer noch sagen, wenn ich mir diesen ganzen Sportgeschiss angucke, was EA so hat und drumherum ist EA eindeutig größer.
Man müsste sich mal die Zahlen angucken.
Ja, und ob Activision Blizzard größer ist, muss man auch mal schauen. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht.
...Entries to the Ultima franchise that were developed hastily under EA's ownership in order to get them out.
But that's a story that repeats itself and repeats itself and repeats itself.
Even with studios that technically EA games started, like Visceral Games.
Which started out as EA Redwood Shores, a subsidiary and eventually grew to create the Dead...
Nee, Visceral ist Dings Dead Space, genau, ähm, Danger Close war, war, ähm, Medal of Honor, ne? Danger Close war das.
Die, die jetzt DICE LA sind, da blickt auch kein Mensch mehr durch, oder?
...Space series, which, again, once it gained any bit of success, EA ran it into the ground, made it into something it wasn't...
Ja, das stimmt.
...forced microtransactions into a narrative-based game and shut the studio down.
Dead Space 2 war so schlecht.
Dead Space hätte keinen Nachfolger gebraucht, ganz ehrlich, ich sag euch wie das ist.
Es war ein super Game und hatte einen richtig schönen Abschluss, auch wenn es natürlich einen Cliffhanger hatte, aber solche Sorten von Spiele...
...gehört was irgendwie fast schon dazu, aber es war abgeschlossen eigentlich.
Ähm, Dead Space 2 war schlecht, Dead Space 2 soll, äh, 3 soll angeblich einen Ticken besser gewesen sein.
Aber, ganz ehrlich, Dead Space hätte an sich keinen Nachfolger gebraucht.
Im Koop, ja, im Koop ist alles geil.
Talk about them rushing Mass Effect Andromeda out.
Ja.
Das war ja auch komplett für Arsch.
...as well as the customers.
In that there was a crunch, the game wasn't done, they forced it out anyway, it dinged their reputation, hurt them probably more than EA itself, which is so big it doesn't matter what people say about it.
And of course was a subpar product that, even if it had been finished properly, didn't even have a full concept until like halfway through the development cycle, which again...
Das, das kommt halt daher, wenn man sagt, Leute, wir brauchen ein neues Mass Effect.
Und der Entwickler sagt, äh, Moment, wir sind doch eigentlich, Mass Effect ist doch eigentlich fertig und wir...
Okay, wir sollen ein neues Mass Effect machen, ja, was machen wir denn?
Egal, fangt schon mal an!
Kann ja nichts Gescheites bei rauskommen.
...was the fault of forcing a quick development cycle.
Of attempting to get BioWare to pursue some games as a service monstrosity.
Oh, Gott.
...while also making a freaking Mass Effect game.
It's no wonder why both turned out like crap.
And again, to bring it back to a single person that they put out there to say things like, I struggle with the external perception that we're just a bunch of bad guys.
You start to understand exactly how it doesn't really matter.
This one individual who is probably trying to do something good with his time at a massive company by bringing in these smaller developers and actually trying to provide material support to people who are trying to make smaller scale games that are more innovative,
and interesting in some cases than these microtransaction laden...
Aber wie gesagt, das Supporten von irgendwelchen Indie-Games ist ja nicht aus reiner Nix, liebe Funny, ey.
...massive games. In fact, there may actually be no one with bad intentions. I'm not going to say that that's true. I will say it's possible.
But ultimately the point of the company, like the point of all companies, is to make money.
And if funding some small Indie-Game now from a passion project Indie-Developer,
who's got great ideas, means they have some kind of contractual obligation from that Indie-Developer,
as well as just some kind of ongoing business relationship with them,
well, later, whether anybody thought about it now or not,
who is now more likely to work with EA, for EA, developing things that make EA look maybe not terrible?
Whether it's entirely philanthropic or not, I don't really care.
It doesn't matter. It absorbs these Indie-Studios into the EA ecosystem,
ultimately going to result in a less good outcome than if they were just successful on their own.
Are they necessarily guaranteed success if they don't sign with EA? I don't know.
But I guarantee the case the EA presents them is that they probably don't have a lot of choice outside the EA ecosystem.
And all of this stuff, all of the crap, whether they do some good stuff behind closed doors, release some good games,
all of the crap is just out there. We see it all the time.
It's impossible not to think about it when they do something new.
And while some single individual may struggle with the external perception that they are just a bunch of bad guys...
Es kann ja auch durchaus sein, dass er wirklich das Gefühl hat, ne?
Das würde ich dem jetzt auch gar nicht absprechen wollen.
Allerdings, wenn man mal 5 Minuten in sich geht, sollte eigentlich jeder drauf kommen, warum die Leute was gegen EA haben.
...single individual may struggle with the external perception that they are just a bunch of bad guys.
Guys, to just reiterate, it doesn't really matter if the guys at EA are good or bad.
It matters what the company does.
And what this company has just repeatedly done to people is shown that it has no confidence, no regard,
or even a lot of cases basic empathy towards its customers.
And even though they might be treating these indie devs and some employees well,
I don't know that I consider that to be like a valid case for them.
People like to try to compartmentalize.
Problems like excessive crunch as of the specific developer.
Like the fact BioWare had excessive crunch for both Anthem and Mass Effect Andromeda.
Somehow that's their problem and not the massive, larger entity that owns them,
placing financial pressure on them to deliver.
Yeah, I don't buy that.
So at this point, there is no good reason not to understand why there is an external perception that they are a bunch of bad guys.
It's because people tend not to separate the individuals from the massive entity,
Yeah, richtig.
Well, I don't personally agree with it.
A lot of people attribute it to, oh, well if it's a bad company, it must be bad people running it.
No, I'm not saying it's good people running it, but I'm saying I don't really make any assumptions
because I know that the end goal of a company is to make money and,
and there's always a pressure to deliver growth in publicly traded companies, which EA is.
The financial incentives will always cause the exact situation we're talking about, good people or bad people at the helm.
It doesn't matter the kind of guys they have at the company.
What matters is what the company does.
And it is routinely negative.
So there you go, EA.
Das ist so.
Ich meine, es gibt keinen mehr, der heute, wenn irgendwie der EA-Marketing-Typ hingeht und wieder was von Player First erzählt,
der das noch glaubt.
Der Ruf ist durch.
Kann mir jemand, der Emixama fragt, kann mir jemand erklären, wie Activision Blizzard so viel Geld macht?
Ich meine, dass EA deutlich mehr größere Titel hat als Activision.
Also, wir haben uns letztens ja mal den Blizzard Financial Report angeguckt.
Blizzard hat WoW.
Und WoW macht Geld.
WoW macht richtig viel Geld, immer noch.
Das Schöne an WoW ist, dass es ein Abo-basiertes Modell ist.
Das heißt, das hat wenige Höhen und Tiefen in dem Sinn.
Es wird nicht so sein, dass alle, keine Ahnung, sagen wir mal 6 Millionen WoW-Abos, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie viele es aktuell gibt,
sie veröffentlichen ja keine Zahlen mehr.
Dass die von einem Modell auf den anderen wegfallen.
Dazu kommt, die haben auch noch ein paar andere große Sachen.
Blizzard hat ihr Dings, wie heißt es, Hearthstone, dieses Kartenspiel gedönst.
Starcraft ist mittlerweile nicht mehr so angesagt.
Sie haben Overwatch.
Allerdings bilde ich mir ein, dass wir in diesem Financial Report gesehen haben, dass Overwatch an sich nicht so der Bringer ist.
Die Overwatch League hält sich auch halbwegs in Grenzen.
Ich denke mal, hauptsächlich Geld wird Blizzard tatsächlich mit WoW und wahrscheinlich Hearthstone verdienen, würde ich jetzt mal so vermuten.
Dazu kommt natürlich noch, wenn man Activision mitnimmt, hast du ja noch, was hat Activision Großes?
Ne, bei COD.
Da musst du mal gucken.
Aber was man nicht vergessen darf und was immer vergessen wird, ist, da wollte ich jetzt nämlich eigentlich drauf raus,
dass bei Activision Blizzard auch noch Mobile Games mit dabei sind.
Weil Activision Blizzard setzt sich zusammen aus Blizzard, aus Activision und aus King Games oder wie sie heißen.
Die da gibt es nämlich auch noch.
Die machen auch einen großen Anteil daran, weil das sind die Candy Crush Dudes.
Unter eine Million Abos bei WoW, das kann ich mir kaum vorstellen.
So, ne.
Das sind die mit so tollen Games wie Bubble Witch Saga, Candy Crush Saga, Pepper Panic Saga.
Die sind da auch am Start.
Und die machen mit Sicherheit auch viel Kohle.
Das ist der Inbegriff von Casual Mobile Gaming Shit.
Aber das zeigt doch, warum Blizzard Diablo Immortal macht.
Warum Blizzard Diablo Immortal macht, die Frage stellt sich mir gar nicht.
Ich finde die Antwort ist relativ offensichtlich, weil Mobile Games Geld bringen.
Allerdings, das auf der BlizzCon anzukündigen, vor Diablo Fans, vor Hardcore Blizzard Diablo Fans,
da muss ich doch mal überlegen, wer auf der BlizzCon ist.
Auf der BlizzCon ist nicht der Candy Crush Spieler.
Auf der BlizzCon ist der Hardcore Blizzard Fan, der auf dem PC spielt. Zu 90%.
Und wenn du da einen Mobile Diablo ankündigst, obwohl sich die Leute seit Jahren schon wünschen, dass sich bei dieser Marke noch ein bisschen was tut,
da musst du dich nicht wundern, wenn das nach hinten losgeht.
Warum Blizzard das macht, ist klar, weil man mit Mobile Games Geld verdienen kann.
Ob Diablo Mobile auch scheiße wird oder nicht, kann man überhaupt nicht sagen.
Das könnte tatsächlich ein gutes Game werden.
Aber das auf der BlizzCon als neues Diablo anzukündigen,
für einen Haufen PC spielender Diablo Blizzard Fans, ist schon ziemlich bescheuert gewesen.
Sie hätten das so machen müssen, wie bei Skyrim.
Skyrim hat ja auch, also Dings, äh äh äh, Possessor und wie heißt denn das Studio von Skyrim?
Wann heißen die irgendwie speziell?
Ich kann mir den ganzen Kram immer aus dem Kopf nicht merken.
Ja, das ist er hier dran.
Okay, Possessor Game Studios.
Ja, gut, ähm, die haben das richtig gemacht.
Die haben ihr, die haben ihr Skyrim Mobile angekündigt
und haben danach den nichtssagendsten Trailer für eine neues Main-Reihe Elder Scrolls aller Zeiten gezeigt.
Das war so ein schlecht, so ein nichtssagender Trailer, äh, was ist denn Elder Scrolls 6 war das, ne?
Genau das da.
Nichtssagend, so ein absolut nichtssagender Trailer.
Ich habe selten einen so nichtssagenden Trailer gesehen, aber die haben es richtig gemacht.
Die haben erst, die haben erst ihr, Moment, ist das überhaupt das Richtige?
Ja doch, das ist das Richtige, genau.
Ähm, die haben erst ihr Mobile Game angekündigt und dann haben sie so hinten dran noch gesagt,
ja, wir sind dran an einem neuen, an einem neuen Elder Scrolls.
Das hätte gereicht bei Blizzard, auch.
Ich meine, als, jetzt, jetzt mal ehrlich, als wäre das hier ein großer Aufwand für Blizzard gewesen,
für Diablo so einen Trailer zu machen.
Jetzt, jetzt, an dieser Stelle ist der Elder Scrolls-Fans schon, der, der ist hier, der, der ist voll hier am Abgehen.
So, sobald der Elder Scrolls-Fans das hier hört, da, da kann er sich nicht mehr halten.
So, das war's, mehr haben die nicht gezeigt.
Das war's, mehr haben die nicht gezeigt.
Und so hätte das Blizzard auch machen müssen, mit, mit einem neuen Diablo.
Die hätten, die hätten ja ihr Mobile gedöhnts zeigen können.
Wäre vollkommen okay gewesen.
Und dann hätten sie einen drei, und mir kann doch keiner erzählen, dass das, guckt euch das an, das ist doch nicht aufwendig.
Das macht, das macht der Azubi in Blender in, in, in, in zwei Tagen macht er das.
Ich meine, was, the fuck, du kannst doch einfach eine alte, eine alte World Map nehmen.
Und dann kannst du in-Game Flyhack anmachen und fliegen.
Da ist nichts Aufwendiges dran.
Und das hätte Blizzard einfach für Diablo auch machen sollen.
Aber Blizzard will sich lieber doofe Fragen stellen lassen danach, ob man, und darauf antworten, ob man nicht auch Smartphones hat.
Jumping from highest points in a Spider-Man-Game.
Was für Videos man hier so alles empfohlen kriegt, ne?
HD-Movies und VHS.
Nun ja, ähm.
Ich hab damals schon gecallt, dass Anthem Crap wird.
Ich finde, man hat Anthem schon seit dem ersten, seit dem ersten Reveal angesehen, dass es Crap wird.
Geht um Battlefield 5.
Battlefield 5 is slowly dying.
Ja, der regt sich da drüber auf, zu Recht.
Battlefield 5 hat sofort verkackt.
Mein Chef auf der Arbeit.
Hab das ja schon ein paar mal erzählt, dass der, der spielt ja Battlefield.
Ich hab sogar noch ein Video von dem irgendwo, wo er, wo er Heli fliegt.
Das müsste ich, muss ich mal gucken, ob ich das noch finde.
Da war er noch zu Zeiten, da war er noch gar nicht mein Chef.
Der spielt auch Battlefield.
Und ich würde schon sagen, dass er jetzt nicht der, der 24-7-Pro ist.
Ähm, eher, eher, eher der Casual-Spieler.
Und sogar der hat keinen Bock mehr auf Battlefield 5.
Der spielt, der spielt wieder Battlefield 1.
Oder Battlefield 4.
Ist dein Chef in deinem Alter.
Ungefähr einen Ticken älter.
Der hat auch keinen Bock mehr auf Battlefield 5.
Das heißt, selbst die guten Battlefield-Spieler haben keinen Bock auf Battlefield 5.
Und die Casuals haben auch keinen Bock mehr auf Battlefield 5.
Was?
Gerücht um Diablo 4, Overwatch 2.
Ja, blablabla.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es in nächster Zeit ein Overwatch 2 gibt.
Ex-Mitarbeiter packt aus.
Wahrscheinlich genauso seriös wie irgendwelche Fake-Trailer.
Glaubt ihr wirklich, dass die sowas in ein Overwatch 2 packen würden?
Das klingt mir nicht nach einer Storyline, die da drinne vorkommt.
Das klingt mir eher nach einer Fan-Fiction-Storyline.
Oh.
Das ist fast wie der Flöten-Typ von Ubisoft.
Das ist... Alter, das ist typ was ein Bullshit, ey.
Das ist total beknackte.
Allein schon, dass der Leak mehr Story enthält.
Und Overwatch hat nun wirklich keinen Story.
Ähm... getriebene Spiele in dem Sinne...
Was ein Blödsinn, ey.
Nichts davon... wow.
Final Fantasy XIV darf in den Büros nicht mehr erwähnt werden.
Das könnte ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen, weil die haben das richtig gemacht.
Die haben die Kurve gekriegt von einem Scheiß-Launch.
Also Final Fantasy Online, also Final Fantasy XIV, hatte wirklich einen richtigen Drecks-Launch damals.
Das Game war auch in einem Zustand, das wollte kein Mensch spielen.
Danach haben sie es überarbeitet, nur in gut und relaunch.
Und siehe da, es war gut.
Und dann haben sie das Spiel gespielt.
Wo steht das mit den 1 Millionen Abos?
Die Abo-Zahlen von WoW sind unter 1 Million gefallen.
Das kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen.
Ich verfolge WoW nicht so genau.
Muss ich zugeben.
Aber ich halte das für zu schnell.
Wann kamen die letzten WoW-Zahlen raus?
2015?
Mit irgendwie 6 Millionen?
Du verlierst in der Zeit mit regelmäßigem Content, verlierst du nicht so viele Abos.
Wobei, man muss sagen, die hatten schon richtigen Crap-Content in WoW.
Ne, ne, die veröffentlichen das nicht.
Das ist irgendwie irgendwas geratenes.
Das ist Blödsinn.
Discord.pn.
Okay.
Silberauer.
Lass ich mal her.
Du hast mir nichts geschickt im Discord.
Weiß nicht, wie du mir was geschickt hast, aber mir nicht.
Nee, du hast mir nichts geschickt.
Was wird es hier stehen?
Ja, wenn Blizzard von Abo-Zahlen spricht, dann meinen die ja immer,
dass wir aktive Abos nicht eingeloggte Spieler oder so.
Ich habe dich nicht geändert.
Aber du kannst mir trotzdem PN schreiben.
Ansonsten schreibst du im Admin-Channel oder so.
Falls es jetzt wichtig ist, dass wir uns das im Stream angucken.
Das ist doch der Sibaro.
Ey, guck mal hier.
Ich kriege Nitro gegiftet vom Sibaro.
Zappt.
Ultranice.
Gilt das jetzt auch für meinen Server?
Global?
Das heißt, ich kann jetzt im Discord, ich kann jetzt Dings hier machen.
Ich kann jetzt 0.3D machen.
Das ist huge.
Ja, dankeschön.
So.
Ah, ja, ja.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche technischen Sachen, die ihr fragen wollt heute oder wissen wollt?
Bisschen Technik-Geschwätze, Gelaber könnten wir heute noch machen.
Ansonsten würde ich mich jetzt nämlich vom Aqua machen.
Windows 10 Design.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mich über das Windows 10 Design noch weiter auslassen will.
Ich habe mich schon oft über das Windows 10 Design ausgelassen.
Generell über das Windows Design.
Wie suboptimal ich das an vielen Stellen finde.
Eigentlich wollte ich heute gar keinen Stream-Bahn machen.
Ich wollte heute eigentlich ein bisschen hier an der Heim-Automatisierung basteln.
Oder irgendwas anderes machen.
Aber ich habe mich dann von Rechner-Gesetzen festgestellt, dass ich eigentlich auf nichts Bock habe.
Und dass ich jetzt eigentlich bloß mich vor den Rechner setzen will und nichts machen will.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, ey, beim nichts machen kann ich auch Stream-Bahn machen.
Team Max Electronics fragt, warum eigentlich kein Node-RED für meine Heim-Automatisierung?
Das kann ich relativ einfach beantworten.
Allerdings, ich muss erstmal Node-RED zeigen für alle, die Node-RED nicht kennen.
Gibt es hier eine Demo?
Gucken wir uns ein paar Bilder an.
Node-RED ist ein, nennen wir es mal ein Workflow-Tool.
Wo man sich, ja hier erkennt man es glaube ich ganz gut, wo man sich Regeln zusammenklicken kann.
Zum Beispiel könnte man sich mit Node-RED Regeln zusammenklicken, wenn man hier beispielsweise auch seine Heim-Automatisierung-Sachen drin hatte.
Könnte man sich eine Regel zusammenklicken.
Der Max ist auf dem Weg heim.
Wenn das der Fall ist und neuer als 5 Minuten, dann schalte die Klimaanlage ein.
Ja, also da kann man sich seine Automatisierung beispielsweise zusammenklicken.
Und ich verwende hier Home Assistant als Heim-Automatisierungslösung.
Und da hast du drei Varianten, wie du deine Automatisierung machen kannst.
Über das Webinterface zusammenklicken oder aber in dem Home Assistant eigenen YAML-Dialekt schreiben.
Das ist so mehr oder weniger das gleiche, weil das Webinterface generiert YAML.
Oder man verwendet Node-RED mit dem Home Assistant Plugin.
Oder man macht das, was ich mache für meine Automatisierung.
Man verwendet, wie hieß das, man verwendet das Home Assistant Python Add-on.
Ich weiß gerade nicht mehr, wie es heißt, ehrlich gesagt, aus dem Kopf.
App Demon verwendet man.
Da kann man nämlich seine komplett, seine komplette Logik und seine kompletten Automatisierungen,
in so einem ekligen YAML-Dialekt zu schreiben, einfach in stinknormalem Python-Code programmieren.
Und das fällt mir viel leichter, als in einem Webinterface irgendwelche Logik zusammenzuklicken.
Ach, du hast ein Beispiel gepostet auf Twitter.
Habe ich gar nicht gesehen. Nach was...
Warum ist denn da meine Katze drin?
Warum habe ich denn meine Katze gefilmt?
Ach, das ist, wo sie unter dem Teppich versucht, irgendwas rauszuziehen.
Ach, die ist doch niedlich, oder?
Also, sie ist ein bisschen zu dick.
Aber das macht sie dann eigentlich noch viel niedlicher.
Meine Katze tritt die Mäuse auch.
Meine Katze fängt Mäuse, nicht die tritt die Mäuse.
Jetzt findet sie den Ball nicht mehr.
Wie lange arbeitest du freitags eigentlich?
Bis mittags oder wegen vier Tage bis nachmittags?
Meistens, meistens. Entweder bis 13.30 Uhr oder bis 14.30 Uhr nur.
Meistens 13.30 Uhr.
13.30 Uhr bin ich freitags eigentlich auf dem Heimweg.
Das funktioniert auch ganz gut.
Ich meine, ich...
Ich arbeite unter der Woche so von...
Ungefähr von sieben bis 15.30 Uhr.
Das sind ja acht Stunden, wenn du eine Pause abziehst.
Big Muffs.
Und ich habe ja nur 7,6 Stunden oder so am Tag.
Dann passt das, dann kann ich freitags 13.30 Uhr abhauen.
Moin Wubblos und Chat.
Habt ihr schon mal gehört, dass im RZ die Server abspielen, weil die Kühlung zu schwach ist?
Nein.
Das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Die meisten Klimaanlagen im RZ
sind überhaupt nicht auf Anschlag.
Der Trend ist mittlerweile eh, dass man es versucht,
nicht kühler zu machen als nötig.
Da ist eigentlich immer noch Reserve da.
Hallo, Klocks, Halle.
Macht es bei dir eigentlich in Frankfurt Sinn,
mit dem Auto zur Arbeit zu fahren,
weil du fährst laut deinen Tweets ja sehr oft mit den öffentlichen...
Ja und ja und nee.
Man könnte das machen.
Das Problem ist, du brauchst einen Parkplatz.
Wir haben bei uns in der Firma keine Parkplätze in dem Sinne,
dass man, man müsste sich irgendwas,
entweder man fährt ins Parkhaus, was ziemlich teuer ist,
oder man mietet sich so einen Stellplatz.
Es gibt manche Parkhäuser und manche Sachen,
da kann man sich sowas mieten.
Oder man parkt ein bisschen außerhalb,
da muss man dann auch wieder eine halbe Stunde laufen.
Alles in allem ist es, auch wenn einem die Bahn auf den Sack geht,
immer noch angenehmer, mit dem Zug zu fahren.
Weil ich meine, ich steige morgen direkt,
also ich gehe aus der Haustür, steige direkt in den Zug ein, quasi.
Ich bin ja quasi direkt in der Nähe vom Bahnhof, steige in den Zug ein,
dann fährt das Ding 25 Minuten, eine halbe Stunde,
dann steige ich Frankfurt Süd aus.
Und früher bin ich immer von Frankfurt Süd
dann mit der U-Bahn noch gefahren, ein Stückchen weiter,
zum Willy-Brandt-Platz.
Allerdings, mittlerweile laufe ich vom Südbahnhof,
das dauert dann nochmal so 25 Minuten.
Aber da hat man sich wenigstens ein bisschen bewegt,
weil ich habe gemerkt, dass, ich meine, ich bin jetzt ja auch 35 Jahre alt,
also ein bisschen älter,
und dass den ganzen Tag vorm Rechner sitzen auf der Arbeit,
plus dann noch irgendwie daheim am Rechner sitzen,
dass das auf Dauer alle möglichen Probleme macht.
Führt hauptsächlich, also bei mir hat es hauptsächlich dazu geführt,
dass ich nicht richtig pennen konnte,
dass es mir teilweise Rückenweh getan hat,
also das, was mir dann voll zu viel Rechner sitzen hat.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ich laufe jetzt einfach morgens ein Stück
und laufe mittags ein Stück,
und dann habe ich mich wenigstens ein bisschen bewegt.
Und das klappt eigentlich ganz gut.
Ab und zu laufe ich sogar noch, wenn Time kommt.
Ja, dann geht das eigentlich halbwegs.
Welche Stühle habt ihr bei euch auf der Arbeit genommen?
Ergonomische? Ja, die neuen Stühle gefallen mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so gut,
aber die alten Stühle waren sehr nice, die wir hatten.
Deswegen habe ich mir den gleichen Stuhl für daheim geholt.
Das ist ein Sedus Mr.24.
Aber sogar, glaube ich, ein Link.
Den gleichen, den der Krieger lustigerweise auch hat.
Den da. Ich habe ihn in der Farbe.
Das ist der beste Stuhl, den es gibt.
Es gibt keinen besseren Stuhl.
Ich mache dazu keinen Reflink.
Und ich empfehle auch keinem, sich den zu kaufen.
Achso doch, wir haben ja dazu sogar einen Reflink.
Wir haben ja da sogar fast einen Reflink.
Also es ist tatsächlich der beste Stuhl, den man sich wünschen kann im Endeffekt.
Allerdings empfehle ich ihn keinem, sich zu kaufen, weil er ist einfach viel zu teuer.
Ich hätte mir den auch nicht gekauft, wenn ich quasi den vollen Preis hätte bezahlt.
Ich habe den gekriegt in irgendeinem Shop.
Der hat anscheinend gerade sein ganzes Kram verkauft.
Da hat er ungefähr 60% vom normalen Preis gekostet.
Ich meine, das ist immer noch verdammt viel Geld für einen Stuhl.
Aber der Stuhl ist extrem gut.
Den habe ich jetzt auch schon ein paar Jahre.
Der macht überhaupt keine Anstalten.
Der ist wie neu.
Also das...
Wenn man viel vorm Rechner sitzt, ist es eine Überlegung wert.
Allerdings kann ich es keinem empfehlen, weil es ist einfach zu teuer.
Mal schauen, ob es bei AliExpress gibt.
Ja, genau.
Kennst du Hermann Miller?
Was sagt mir irgendwas?
Ich könnte mir sogar...
Ist das nicht irgendein Stuhldesigner-Typ?
Was?
Naja...
Der sieht mir schon viel zu fancy designt irgendwie aus.
Das ist für die Leute,
wo der Bauch nicht nur nach da geht,
sondern auch schon so in die Seite,
dass du die Lehne nicht mehr absprengst.
So schlimm ist es bei mir zum Glück nicht.
Kostet was?
Kostet ungefähr das Gleiche.
Also ich würde mir meinen Stuhl auf jeden Fall wiederholen.
Das ist der beste Stuhl, den es gibt.
Ganz witzig ist, wir hatten mal vor ewig keinen.
Da hatten wir einen Kollegen auf der Arbeit.
Der hat es geschafft.
Also der war sehr...
sehr füllig.
Der hat es geschafft,
bei seinem Stuhl die Armlehnen abzusprengen.
Das war halt nicht so ein Stuhl.
Das war halt ein normaler Bürostuhl.
Und der Stuhl, wo der drauf gesessen hat,
haben immer die Armlehnen nach unten gehangen.
Weil die waren halt rausgesprengt aus dem Rahmen.
Das war auch hart.
Leute, wisst ihr, dass man sowas heute gar nicht mehr sagen darf?
Das grenzt schon fast an Fatshaming und Hatespeech wieder.
Wobei ich das eigentlich sagen darf.
Ich bin ja selbst nicht der Allerdünste.
Allerdings davon bin ich noch ein Stückchen entfernt.
Hexo, ihr habt auch die Mister24-Stühle?
Die sind super.
Die sind top.
Ein Stuhl für 1,95€ inklusive Versand auf AliExpress.
Zeigt mal.
Schickt mal einen Link.
Also ich denke, wenn man schon so viel Bauch hat,
dass man nicht mehr gerade in die Toilette rein kann,
dann ist es zu viel.
Wenn man sich quasi umdrehen muss und rückwärts in die Toilette einpacken muss,
Dann ist alles vorbei, ey.
Ne, ich habe es euch ja erzählt.
Ich habe jetzt fast acht Kilo abgenommen.
Einfach durch, wer hätte das gedacht, weniger essen.
Das habe ich schon vor zwei Wochen erzählt oder so.
Aber es ist jetzt auch nicht mal weniger geworden.
Das wird sich jetzt auch so ein bisschen halten.
Übrigens, hier, guck mal, AliExpress-Stuhl.
AliExpress-Stuhl.
Für 1,95€ inklusive Versand.
Huge.
Gelber Stuhl bei AliExpress.
Ich will nicht wissen, was in diesem Polster drin ist.
Also erstens ist der wahrscheinlich in Kinderarbeit hergestellt.
Und zweitens ist er wahrscheinlich in diesem Polster,
ist wahrscheinlich der Materialabfall von der 3D-Drucker-Herstellung oder sowas drin.
Ich meine, das sieht schon billig aus auf dem Bild hier, ne?
Ich würde das zu gerne, zu gerne einfach mal bestellen,
um zu gucken, was da wirklich ankommt.
Einfach nur gucken, was da ankommt.
Was ist das für ein hässlicher Stuhl hier neben?
Hallo, das habe ich nicht ausgelesen.
Ein Stretchstuhl.
Das ist aber geil, oder?
Wie groß ist der? Eine gute Frage.
Manuelle Messung.
Es wird ein Fehler von ca.1cm.
Und manchmal die Farbe, vielleicht haben weniger Fehler errado.
Oh, verstehe.
Ich hoffe, Sie verstehen können dankend im Voraus.
Ich könnte es nicht verstehen.
Ich kann nur schwer verstehen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich glaube, er möchte uns mitteilen,
Dass quasi das, was hier steht, nicht unbedingt zutreffen muss.
Dass es abweichen kann um bis zu einen Zentimeter.
Wie wäre es mit Höhe?
Also D ist was?
42 Zentimeter.
Also dann ist der Stuhl irgendwie 80 Zentimeter oder so insgesamt hoch.
Ungefähr.
Scheint ein ganz normaler Stuhl zu sein.
Aber.
Qualität genial.
Bin sehr zufrieden.
Die Qualität ist bestimmt absolut genial bei dem 1,95 Euro Stuhl.
Bestimmt die beste Qualität überhaupt.
Oh, der ist gerade reduziert.
Ja guck mal.
Normalerweise kostet der ja unglaubliche Wucher.
4 Euro kostet der normalerweise.
Das ist ja voll übertrieben.
4 Euro für den Stuhl.
Wer gibt 4 Euro für den Stuhl aus?
Also 1,60 Euro kann ich mit mir reden, aber für 4 Euro nicht.
Bei dem anderen geht es nur um die Abdeckung.
Ach, das ist nur die Abdeckung.
Das ist gar nicht der Stuhl.
Haha, lol, she baited.
Da steht es.
Das ist nur die Abdeckung.
Geil.
Dieses hässliche Ding hier drüber.
Okay.
Ja, das ergibt.
Das ergibt ein bisschen mehr Sinn.
Weil ich wollte gerade sagen, so 1,60 Euro für den Stuhl ist schon verdammt wenig.
Das ist übrigens auch was, was ich gerne in Videos machen würde.
Ich bestelle ja mittlerweile relativ viel.
Ähm.
China-Kram und generell online viel.
Das hatte ich eh vor, dass ich ab und zu mal ein Video mache.
Also wenn ich denn dann wirklich mal wieder Videos mache und auch ein bisschen mehr Technik-Videos mache.
Wo ich einfach mal so die neuesten Sachen.
Ja, die neuesten interessanten Sachen kaufe.
Äh, zeige, die ich gekauft habe.
Zum Beispiel die China-Steckdosen-Leiste, die man flashen kann, ja.
Oder den 50er-Pack USB-Kabel.
Die übrigens immer noch nicht da sind.
Nur mal angemerkt.
Und ich frage mich, ob es wirklich jetzt ein 200er-Pack oder echt nur der 50er-Pack ist.
Ich meine, ich habe nur einen 50er-Pack bestellt.
Aber man weiß ja nie, ne.
Der Sibaro hat einen Stuhl für 9 Dollar gefunden.
Ja, 9 Dollar lasse ich mir so einen billigen Holzstuhl noch gefallen.
Einfach eine Kamera an die Decke hängen und mit der Elgato capturen.
Ja, könnte man machen.
Brauche ich ein bisschen ordentliche Beleuchtung.
Habe ich ja. Habe ich ja da.
Müsste ich halt mal rüberholen.
Findest du, dass Made in China mittlerweile einen besseren Status haben sollte, als der traditionell hat?
Made in China, oder generell, das ist halt sehr gemischt, ne.
Du kannst den Ultra-Crap aus China bestellen.
Und du kannst gutes Zeug aus China bestellen.
Allerdings, es ist im Prinzip ein bisschen wie hier.
Ja.
Den Crap, also die billigen Sachen sind meistens Crap und die teuren Sachen haben zumindest das Potential gut zu sein.
Also ich finde schon, dass Made in China oder generell China-Produkte teilweise zu unrecht einen schlechten Ruf haben.
Zum Beispiel, wie gesagt, den Staubsauger-Roboter, den ich mir gekauft habe, der ist besser, als das, was du hier kriegst, für einen unschlagbaren Preis.
Wenn er im Angebot ist, wohlgemerkt.
Sind die China-Sachen aber laufend, irgendwie.
Ja.
Und der Eiskräuter hat Recht.
Wenn es um Elektronik-Teile geht, dann kann man die bedenkenlos aus China bestellen.
Weil die Teile an sich sind entweder nachgebaut, aber bei einzelnen Elektronik-Teilen ist das nicht so wild.
Weil entweder machen sie das, wofür sie da sind, oder sie machen das nicht.
Oder es ist exakt der gleiche Kram.
Ich meine, ob du jetzt einen Widerstand holst, von hier, oder eine Widerstandskiste in den Widerstandskasten.
Wenn du eine Widerstandskiste in der Kiste mit Widerständen aus China bestellst, ist es wurscht.
Ich meine, du kannst mit China-Zeug schon ganz schön gescampt werden.
Ich würde mir beispielsweise keine Grafikkarte aus China kaufen und auch keine CPU aus AliExpress.
Weil die sind ja bekannt dafür, dass sie beispielsweise alte Nvidia-Karten nehmen und quasi nur das BIOS flashen und sie dann für etwas Neueres verkaufen.
Oder dass sie...
Also man muss aber schon sagen, die Chinesen sind echt erfinderisch.
Ne?
Die Chinesen haben hier Intel-CPUs.
Das sind tatsächlich echte Intel-CPUs.
Allerdings sind das alte Notebook-CPUs, die sie quasi an einen Desktop-Socket dran gepappt haben.
Ich sehe jetzt hier keinen.
Aber die Chinesen sind da echt erfinderisch, was das angeht.
Also das würde ich mir nicht unbedingt kaufen.
Elektronik-Teile auf jeden Fall.
Bringen die dieselbe Leistung?
Ja, dieselbe Leistung, wie sie in dem Notebook auch gebracht haben.
Call-to-do in 2K19 in China.
Du kriegst bei AliExpress mehr oder weniger alles.
Es gibt nichts, was du nicht auf AliExpress kriegst.
Also nichts, was halbwegs üblich ist.
Du kriegst alles auf AliExpress.
Alles.
Außer Essen.
Oder haben die auch Food?
Nee, haben sie nicht.
Doch.
Sbarro.
Klar, gibt es auch.
Gibt alles.
Gibt mehr als bei Amazon.
Es gibt alles.
Bei AliExpress.
Es gibt für Sbarro wahrscheinlich sogar Waifu-Pillows.
Bam.
Waifu-Pillows von Sbarro.
Gibt es alles.
Alles auf AliExpress.
Falls das was wirklich ist.
Nix Monkertoss.
War alles angezogen.
Nachtbot.
Abonniert auf Stufe 1.
Dankeschön.
Ja.
Eiskräuter ist so.
Ich kaufe den ganzen Sensorkram auch nur in China.
Man muss halt manchmal ein bisschen warten.
Aber am besten ist, man bestellt sich halt dann ordentliche Mengen auch aus China.
Also nicht irgendwie ein Sensor und losschicken.
Nee, man bestellt sich alle möglichen Sensoren, die man braucht.
Am besten natürlich beim gleichen Shop.
Wie gesagt, AliExpress ist ja nicht so wie Amazon.
Amazon.
Diskriminieren hier keine Twitch Prime Benutzer.
Hattest du eigentlich schon mal Probleme mit Zoll wegen AliExpress?
Nee.
Ich hatte bisher nur Probleme mit Zoll, wenn ich quasi ganz korrekt beispielsweise aus den USA bestellt habe.
Also so richtig auch mit allem, wie man das so macht.
Da musst du dann FAT bezahlen, dann musst du Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen und du musst, wenn es über 150 Euro ist, noch Zollgebühren bezahlen.
Bei AliExpress ist es so, wie viel bekommt man denn von den 5 Zollern ab?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube standardmäßig ohne extra Custom Twitch Vertrag, ich glaube die Hälfte.
Müsst du mal nachgucken, ich glaube die Hälfte.
Also ich hatte noch nie Zollprobleme mit AliExpress.
Das liegt aber auch daran, dass sie das glaube ich recht geschickt machen mittlerweile.
Wenn du den normalen Versandweg nimmst bei AliExpress, dann kommt das dann mit irgendeinem Schiff aus China oder so.
Die kommen dann in Rotterdam, in den Niederlanden irgendwo an.
Und von da geht es mit PostNL weiter.
Also ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob AliExpress Sendungen jemals den Zoll sehen.
Ich weiß nicht an welcher Stelle das gemacht werden müsste.
Eigentlich müsste das nicht so sein.
Eigentlich müsste das ja in den Niederlanden gemacht werden, wenn sie da landen.
Keine Ahnung wie sie das machen.
Und dazu kommt noch, dass die wahrscheinlich auch einfach die Sachen sehr optimistisch deklarieren.
Die deklarieren es ordnungsgemäß.
Allerdings was die draufschreiben wird wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt immer so der Realität entsprechen.
Du hast darüber eine Arbeit geschrieben, okay.
China hat in Griechenland einen Hafen aufgekauft.
Ja gut, in Griechenland war wahrscheinlich der Hafen auch billig.
Machst du irgendwann mal wieder eine Runde BF3 mit der Community?
Könnte man machen.
Wo machst du am liebsten Urlaub?
Also bisher muss ich sagen am besten.
Also der beste Urlaub war in der Türkei.
Allerdings ist das schon ewig her.
Aber auch nur weil wir da mit mehreren Leuten da waren.
Am besten gefallen würde ich sagen hat es mir auf Gran Canaria.
Das hat mir am besten gefallen.
Also von der.
Von drumherum.
Gran Canaria ist das beste ja.
Wie schauen deine Urlaube aus?
Bahnurlaub oder Sachen anschauen?
Beides.
Allerdings ich muss dir ehrlich sagen.
Ich glaube ich war die letzten fünf Jahre nicht mehr irgendwo so klassisch im Urlaub.
Wo ich nochmal hinfahren würde ist nach Island.
Allerdings muss ich auch sagen so richtig in Urlaub fahren.
Da brauchst du ja noch Leute die mitgehen.
Und ich bin jetzt nicht mehr in dem Alter wo ich da jetzt.
Wo ich irgendwie großartige RL Freunde hätte die da mitfahren.
Die sind ja selbst alle beschäftigt mit Familie, Kinder sonst was.
Tja und deswegen denke ich mal bis ich vielleicht mal irgendwann.
Zumindest naja sagen wir mal Kinder außen vor ja.
Aber bis dahin werde ich wahrscheinlich dann erstmal nicht in Urlaub fahren.
Weil alleine habe ich keinen Bock.
Was natürlich nicht verkehrt ist.
Weil die letzten paar Jahre habe ich so gemacht.
Ich habe einfach zu den Zeitpunkten wo alle Urlaub wollten.
Habe ich nie Urlaub genommen.
Und dafür habe ich mich dann immer von der Arbeit den kompletten Dezember verpisst.
Deswegen habe ich eigentlich den kompletten Dezember immer Zeit für.
Stremsäuren und Videos wenn ich Videos mache.
Aber ich mache ja in letzter Zeit wenige Videos.
Ich weiß aber da habe ich im Dezember habe ich immer ganzen Monat Zeit.
Die Beide Videos ja.
Aida.
War da nicht der Krieger.
Was hältst du von 360 Kameras.
Äh.
In welchem Anwendungsgebiet wofür genau.
Weil für normale Aufnahmen sind die ja nix.
Das sieht ja ein bisschen.
Rund aus.
360 Kameras für normales Zeug.
Außer halt vielleicht mit.
VR Brille dass man sich dann da drinnen dreht und immer noch ein Teil angezeigt kriegt oder sowas.
Holzfahrtschriften sind voll mit Rentnern.
Kein Schimmer.
Aber ich kenne ein paar Leute die sind.
Auch schon.
In Urlaub auf Kreuzfahrtschiff gegangen.
Das sind keine Rentner.
Aber auf ein Kreuzfahrtschiff müsste ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Ich gammelste dann den ganzen Tag ums Schiff rum.
Naja ein paar Sachen angucken.
Schon nicht verkehrt.
Wobei ich halt kein Bock habe auf diese Standard Tourismus Kulturprogramm dann.
Da hat ja jedes Land und jede Ecke hat so vier fünf Sehenswürdigkeiten wo so alle Touristen hinkarren.
Willst du zu dem Video reacten.
Ich glaube das kenne ich.
Ja ja das kenne ich.
Das ist richtig gut.
Das ist gut.
Das kenne ich.
Das können wir uns angucken.
Das Video ist wirklich lustig.
Also für alle für alle JavaScript für alle JavaScript Fans.
Die müssen jetzt stark sein.
Das ist lustig.
Das geht auch nur.
Das geht auch nur vier Minuten oder so.
Ihr wisst, was Watt bedeutet.
Watt.
Genau genau.
Lass uns über Ruby sprechen.
Ach Ruby? Nicht JavaScript.
Okay.
In Ruby.
Wenn du eine unbefundete Variante nennst, kommt das natürlich zu Namenverlusten.
Wie du erwartet hättest.
Und wenn du versuchen versuchst eine B dazu A zu assignieren.
Mit denen unbefindetes Nenner 맞uiert.
Das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen unlogisch, ja.
Ja, das ist, das ist Ruby, das ist typischer Ruby-Style. Das verwirrt jeden, der mit Ruby anfängt, diese Method Missing-Geschichte.
Ja, das ist, das ist Ruby, das ist Ruby-Logik. Wie das funktioniert, ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Diese Funktion, Method Missing, wird aufgerufen, immer wenn du was aufrufst, was es nicht gibt.
Und in dem Fall, nimmt er halt die Sachen, die es nicht gibt, als Argumente hierfür und macht einen String draus.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Das ist wirklich cool bei Ruby.
Aber wenn du das tatsächlich tust, dann...
Alter, warum pissen sie sich so weg, ey?
Übertreibt man Ruby.
Ja, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt kommt der gute Teil.
Wisst ihr, was rauskommt?
Was kommt raus? Leeres Array plus leeres Array?
Lass mal überlegen. Es ist JavaScript.
Leeres Array, also logisch, logisch wäre, leeres Array plus leeres Array gibt ein leeres Array.
Die Frage ist nur, ob man in JavaScript, ähm, leere Arrays mit plus überhaupt zusammenhängen kann.
Und ich denke mal, das geht nicht.
Und deswegen wird er wahrscheinlich versuchen, das Array umzuwandeln in irgendeinen Typ, der, den man addieren kann.
Das heißt, das, was der Sibaro sagt, ist gar nicht so unlogisch, dass da not a number rauskommt.
Aber es kann alles sein, das ist JavaScript.
Array plus Array, well, let me ask you this first.
What should Array plus Array be?
Empty Array.
Empty Array, I would also accept type error.
That is not what Array plus Array is.
Wrong. Wrong.
Array plus Array is empty string.
What?
Warum?
Wandel deine leeres Array um in den String und...
Leerer String plus leerer String.
Leerer String ist leerer String, oder was?
Okay, JavaScript.
Obviously, I think that's obvious to everyone.
Now, what would Array plus Object...
Ach du Scheiße, keine Ahnung.
Da kommt jetzt not a number raus.
Da kommt jetzt...
Irgendwann muss in JavaScript immer not a number rauskommen.
This should obviously be type error, because those are completely disparate types.
Does anyone know what this is?
No.
No, far away.
It's object.
It's ob...
Okay, das mit Object ergibt sogar halbwegs Sinn.
Halbwegs.
In JavaScript-Logik ergibt das sogar halbwegs Sinn.
Das ist ein Object, ein leeres, aber es ist ein Object.
Und das ist ein Array.
Und das zusammen...
ist ein Object-Array, oder?
Wie auch immer.
Ist das überhaupt ein Object-Array?
Oder ist das nur ein Object?
So ein Object, ne?
Wo ist das Array hin?
Ja, leider noch keine Sub-Icons.
Ich hab's noch nicht auf die Reihe gerechnet.
Mir haben auch die guten Ideen gefehlt.
Now, of course, because this is plus, so you can flip the operands and the same thing comes out.
So, if we do...
What?
No, that's just a...
Das ist jetzt not a number.
Ich hab mir angewöhnt, wenn man in JavaScript keine Ahnung hat, was rauskommt,
man muss es nur oft genug in verschiedenen Kombinationen probieren und irgendwann kommt not a number raus.
Okay.
If you do object plus Array, you get exactly the same thing, which, as you can see, you do.
Und nein, jetzt ist es null.
Okay.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, warum da null rauskommt.
And finally, the only one of these that's actually true is...
Because, you know, you add Arrays, you get an empty string, that doesn't make sense.
But an object plus an object is actually not a number.
Okay, das ist mir.
Das ist nice.
Not a number.
Endlich haben wir mal not a number.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Pöpega.
Alter, wie sie sich wegpissen.
Ey, endlich mal ein Talk-Publikum, was gut drauf ist.
If I say Array.new 16, or just Array 16, I get...
Naja, da weiß ich jetzt, was kommt.
Da kommt jetzt Batman gleich.
... an Array of 16 things, which it represents as 16 commas, which is obvious.
Voll klar, dass da 16 Kommas rauskommen.
Wobei die 16 Kommas wahrscheinlich intern sowas wie sind.
Null.
Null, null, null, null, null, null, null.
Also spricht der Wandel das einfach, dass man es besser lesbar kann, um in eben eine String-Repräsentation von dem Inhalt von dem Array.
Und es ist halt einfach Null, nächstes Element, Null, nächstes Element.
Also das ergibt Sinn.
And if I then join those with a string, then I get the string 16 times.
Das ergibt auch Sinn.
Du joinst halt Null.
Du joinst 16 mal Null mit Wort zusammen.
Das ist okay, das ist ja im Prinzip das Trennzeichen.
Und es ist halt nichts dazwischen.
Das ergibt auch noch Sinn.
This is actually the only line in this entire presentation that's reasonable.
Now if I take that string and then add a 1 to it, it interprets the 1, or casts the 1 to a string.
Okay, das leuchtet mir auch noch irgendwo ein.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Was kommt da raus?
Macht er dann nur noch war raus?
String minus 1.
Was könnte das?
Not a number.
Da kommt jetzt, da kommt jetzt not a number raus, Leute.
Das ist, das ist das Einzige.
Was ich mir irgendwie erklären könnte.
I'm assuming no one does.
Let me, I'll give you a hint.
Does, does this help?
Ja, das kenne ich.
Klar, das habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal on stream gezeigt.
Das ist, das ist ja wirklich, das ist saubekannt, die Geschichte jetzt.
Was da rauskommt.
Da kommt jetzt na na na na na na na Batman raus.
Does anyone know?
Wieso gehen die alles so ab?
Weil es halt die krassen Programmer-Geeks sind.
Find das auch lustig.
Und nicht so lustig, sondern ich finde das wirklich lustig.
Und die sind halt mal gut drauf.
Endlich mal ein Talk mit dem Publikum, was gut drauf ist.
Ich meine, okay, die eskalieren halt voll jetzt, aber es ist schon abgedreht, muss man sagen.
Ich meine, ich kenne das hier schon jetzt, ne.
Das ist bekannt.
Das ist, das ist saubekannt.
Das ist ein guter Talk.
Das Publikum ist, das Publikum ist so eingespielt.
Nein, die finden das einfach lustig.
Die finden das lustig.
Das ist, also, wenn man JavaScript-Programmierer ist oder überhaupt, wenn man ein bisschen was damit zu tun hat
und schon mal JavaScript-Wirren gesehen hat, dann ist das, das ist, das ist tatsächlich echt lustig.
Ja, Sibaro.
Warum hatten wir überhaupt einen Discord-Invite-Link, der nur in den Weeb-Channel geführt hat?
Aber haben wir mittlerweile einen ordentlichen Invite-Link?
Ich will die Leute nicht standardmäßig abschrecken, also nicht defaultmäßig abschrecken,
wenn sie im Weeb-Channel rauskommen unter Sibaro nachts um, ähm,
um 2 Uhr ein Ding up-postet.
Ja, dann, Ray, dann bist du halt da immun dagegen.
Kann ja sein, ja.
Ey, ich fand das lustig.
Wie heißt das JS-Ding von Microsoft, was da jetzt kommt?
Kommt ein JS-Ding von Microsoft?
Ich weiß nur, dass Bing jetzt Chrome ist.
Oder man zu Blazor, was wir uns gestern angeguckt haben.
Blazor haben wir uns gestern angeguckt.
Allerdings Blazor ist keine, kein JavaScript.
Blazor ist ein komplettes .NET im Browser.
Und auch hat mit JavaScript gar nichts zu tun.
Ja, Bildschirmarbeiter, das ist gefährlich.
Das habe ich auf der Arbeit auch gemacht im Discord.
Und jetzt fragt mich Discord nicht mehr,
ob ich wirklich weiterklicken will im Discord-Channel.
Und wenn ich jetzt aus Versehen auf den Weeb-Channel im Discord klicke,
kommen da irgendwelche nackten Anime-Grills.
Das ist nicht so sinnvoll, wenn ich das auf dem Monitor auf der Arbeit anzeige.
Willst du Monka Winwald in den Chat-Client packen?
Funktioniert nicht, weil der Chat-Client ist,
also wenn du den hier meinst,
der ist, die Emotes sind gefaked.
Das ist mit einem Browser-Add-on.
Und wenn das kein offizielles Emote ist, funktioniert es nicht.
Das Overlay, Overlay ist genauso.
Das ist ein Overlay von Streamlabs.
Und das zeigt nur Emotes an, die offiziell in dem Channel drin sind.
Das heißt, ich müsste bei FFZ quasi Monka Win oder sowas,
oder Java S haben wir ja auch auf dem Discord,
ähm, müsste ich dann als offizielles Emote einreichen bei FFZ,
dass ich es bei mir im Channel hinzufügen könnte.
Muss ich mal überlegen, wie wir das machen.
Ich hätte viel lieber so Emotes in der Richtung direkt, direkt auf Twitch.
Also ich will auf jeden Fall ein Java Flame Emote.
Was man immer mal verwenden kann.
Ins Memeboard, ja, da kann ich es reinmachen.
Weil wir haben jetzt ja auf, im Discord haben wir jetzt ja einen extra,
äh, für Windows.
Ich habe mir auch schon überlegt, was auch ein richtig gutes Windows Emote wäre.
Ist hier easy, bloß mit blauen Gläsern für Blue Screen.
Das wäre auch ein ganz gutes Emote.
Äh, was ist denn das, das, wo ist denn das Bild für Monka Win?
Oh, das Stream ist on.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Ist hier Monka Win drin?
Ah, hier.
Das kann man hier, Link öffnen.
Bayon.
Monka S3.
Okay, gut.
Was, Monka S3.
Ja, nice.
Ah, ist hier auch drin.
Monka Win.
Monka, hm, ja, das, das, das könnte ich echt noch machen.
Okay, mal gucken, wie wir hosten können.
Ich programmiere mir die Welt.
Wen haben wir denn da?
Was programmiert er denn?
Was ist das?
WordPress?
Das ist WordPress.
Na, Autofill2Challenger, was ist das?
Das ist .NET.
Das ist mir schon mal sympathisch.
NoobDevTV.
Das ist auch .NET.
Und ganz viele Messages hier neben.
Was programmiert er da?
Eine Minecraft-Klone oder was gibt das?
Local Chunk Cache.
Dann hätten wir noch zu bieten, Android Flutter App.
Der ist jeden Tag on, ne?
Den haben wir jetzt schon öfters gesehen.
Nee, das ist ein anderer.
Und der 3D-Drucker ist natürlich am Start.
Wer sonst?
Was, wer ist geil?
Sharks Development.
Der da?
Autofill2Challenger.
Jedes Mal.
Wie bei dem anderen auch.
Der macht's richtig.
Console Debugging.
Das einzig wahre.
Das hört sich jetzt so an, als will ich in Flame.
Will ich gar nicht.
Das ist so.
Macht das selber so.
Wer braucht schon Debugger?
Beste.
Console Debugging.
Ja, das ist natürlich nur halb ernst gemeint.
Das hat schon seinen Anwendungszweck.
Aber für einfache Sachen ist beste.
Nichts geht über Console Debugging.
Wirtschaftswissenschaften im Studium.
Das hat immer null Zuschauer.
Das liegt aber einfach auch daran, weil BWL-Shit einfach langweilig ist.
Ich meine, wer guckt sich freiwillig BWL-Karten an?
Mach das weg.
Ich. Ja, es kommen immer welche, die es angeblich
gucken.
Pics all didn't happen.
Ich glaube euch kein Wort, dass ihr das guckt.
Was programmiert er denn eigentlich?
Was programmiert er denn hier?
Models.
Main.
Es sieht ein bisschen nach WPF aus.
Login-Window.
Ein Twitch-Bot.
Ja, ergibt Sinn.
Der macht es richtig.
Erstmal in Ruhe.
Zurücklehnen, überlegen.
So macht man es.
Den hauste ich. Der ist gut.
Okay, Leute. Also.
Wir sehen uns die Tage wieder.
Bis dahin.
Monk Kavin.
Und wir sehen uns. Bis denn.
See you.